peu
[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe là tout le
monde aux coutumes par l'aventuré comme
quoi la radio ou la télé les journaux
tout le monde enfin à l'autre
oui oui ce matin chez lui au pressing
m'attends à tout moment pas à l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu trois
quarts en réglant aventure parler aussi
mieux si on paye aussi leurs passifs ils
en parlent ça veut dire que tout le
monde encore
voici le nouvel épisode tout le monde en
bas
[Applaudissements]
les avis sont
jean philippe corti
il y a
izia
[Applaudissements]
mais à
moyen
amy de télévision
[Applaudissements]
guest star du soir ophélie winter
à
mais le mercier
croque notes
josiane
l'ex spice victoria beckham
conduit plein elle est
benjamin biolay
à
le samedi soir
bien vu sur le plateau de tout le monde
en parle l'émission pas comme les autres
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez les kiwos hyland avis
et oui non un pis aller
mais attention lors
anciaux l'on a
le film ne passera pas et des baptistes
ce soir il ya trois bâtisses nom alors
je suis retourné voir votre pièce de
théâtre beaucoup d'améliorations sur le
texte encore mieux qu'au départ daniel
russo et mieux que l'acteur précédent
sans comparaison plus en comparaison
avec on peut dire son nom
bernard farcy un pascal sellem mado
maurin faut faire attention quel âge
elle a maintenant 86 ans oui si tu veux
excellente comédienne non mais on fêtera
ses 100 ans sur scène on arrête un deal
entre no way
et voilà c'est joe dame d'amour mado
dans cette pièce c'est parti pour être
boing boing quoi parce que ça quand tu
aimes ces régions plus la cage aux
folles que boeing boeing
ouais alors les inconvénients maintenant
les gens rient beaucoup et il oublie
complètement la troisième guerre
mondiale c'est marrant ça c'est un truc
qu'on n'avait pas prévu au départ
on est assez content c'est à dire que
les gens
vienne se changer les idées pendant
trois heures et c'est comme un lavage
intérieur
on peut aussi se cacher un peu c'est une
carte irisation à linthal alors beaucoup
du mail toujours beaucoup beaucoup du
mail de l'étranger grâce à tv5 que nous
remercions et que nous saluons ici
varsovie guadalajara au mexique
singapour saint pierre de saint pierre
et miquelon novossibirsk en sibérie
ils ont tv5 vous voyez des gens qui
envoient des emails deux ans aussi bien
ce frigo ils ont la télé voilà à l'île
maurice aussi et puis en france bat sur
tv5 eurodif de l'émission l'heure est
écrite en bas de l'écran
à nîmes l2 daniel r blé qui me dit
pourrais-tu annoncé la date de la venue
dans ton émission de la mer de jeane
manson
on cherche
là
et valérie de reims qui dit j'ai appelé
mon animal domestique ardisson car il
est tout noir mais c'est quoi tout
animal domestique un cafard
il ya une tradition dans cette émission
c'est de regarder chaque semaine les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean luc morel magnéto
c'est le plus grand moment de votre vie
là mon premier disque séparé maman c'est
quoi votre premier disque
c'est ce que ça veut dire kylie ça veut
dire [ __ ] en
vous pouvez vraiment un gros cul
jennifer lopez s'est dit après la
rencontre et la bbc cette boîte est
changée ce déficit mais vous aime bien
jean marie messier le patron de vivendi
universal mais il se dit c'est un c'est
un homme de télé formidable lescure
mais c'est pas un patron mélissa tout le
temps tout le temps partout dès qu'il a
un coup dans le cornet de chier dessus
man a pris naissance dans le combat 73%
des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour le
soir au coucher
non non pas du tout bien annonce oui oui
n'est pas non mais vous c'est quoi le
matin le matin soit aussi comique
65% des femmes refusent des relations à
3 vous aussi ça vous intéresse pas non
vous n'avez jamais essayé à 1 comment je
les connais je suis content
non mais des fois il ya des voyeurs
thierry thierry leur barre ouais
en plus il est imité
été remarquée à toulouse mais oui
vous êtes sade au château adorable
dépend la personne qui serait bien
contente que tout dépend des goûts de
l'autre oui docile bien ce que vous êtes
sous dos ça dépend de la personne
oh
nombreux amateurs d'or où vous remercier
le comité des odeurs qui vous remet
officiellement le hot d'or bonheur ah
oui à mon nom est tout autant
un genre d'impulsion je le donne à
lescure insultes qui ne mérite premier
baiser
quel âge d'abord sur la bouche h qu'elle
a 14 ans très bien avec qui le prennent
en s'appelait 10 2vic nom cyrill exact
première saudeau et fellation en même
temps j'ai la réponse aussi ils étaient
deux dans projet x déjà aux mains des
femmes sur canal
c'était tout
le
la semaine pressées
[Applaudissements]
alors quand vous le savez la fin des
missions et humble à intel ce blind test
sera consacré ce soir au groupe de
filles en hommage à victoria beckham
l'ex spice girl qui est l'une de nos
invités ce soir pour arbitrer ce blind
j'appelle un homme au dessus de tout
soupçon
j'avais les bordés
à
m
les
[Musique]
la maison on va passer au jeu idiot ce
soir le jeu idiot c'est le limbo
bien alors le connaissez bimbo c'est
quoi tes une contraction de limay la
bimbo aux notes il faut passer sous le
bâton méline accessoires à attention est
pas pareil musiquemag
reflet le bâton elle ne te prend bien le
bâti à leur tiennent bien le bateau
intentions bien bas bien bas sinon ça va
toujours devant toute la nation
il est content musique maestro
patricia gagné bravo d'issia
et dans le titien comme titien s'il vous
plaît j'ai reçu beaucoup du mail me
disant que je faisais du favoritisme
pour thalia je vais vous offrir titia du
temps d'exposition télévisuel dont vous
allez vous mettre là à côté de laurent
baffie exposé médiatiquement pendant une
quinzaine de minutes voilà vous restiez
lavalas
c'était le jeu idiot
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant vers winter et
gilles paquet brenner d'amour
pas d brenner ophélie winter bonsoir en
fait j'ai gagné un 7 d'or bien loeb au
bien au fait lycée pour pâques on vous
compare à loana que vous êtes fait
brunir un peu les cheveux comment vous
savez ah ouais non non je vais j'ai
envie de rester comme ça ouais
gilles paquet brenner dont vous êtes le
réalisateur d'un film qui s'appelle les
jolies choses avec marion cotillard
stomy bugzy patrick bruel titoff et
ophélie winter voulez que je fasse le
pitch vous le faites
allez-y je vais faire le pitre chercher
ça c'est l'histoire de deux soeurs
m
alors il ya deux soeurs jumelles y avait
une qui s'appelle lucie une qui
s'appelle marie mais elles ont
absolument rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre
lucie c'est un peu la bimbo d'infos
prête à tout pour réussir
maryse c'est le côté obscur repliée sur
elle même complètement at his yann en
mouvement non en plus c'est prohibitif
comme puis voilà donc la deuxième mari
elle est complètement repliée sur elle
même elle est complètement bunkérisé et
un jour lucie est sollicité pour faire
un disque elle sait pas chanter
elle demande à marie de prendre sa place
et pendant ce temps là lui six suicides
et marie est obligé d'endosser la
personnalité de sa soeur c'était une
personnalité qui lui ressemble pas du
tout évidemment
alors il ya un témoin de l'histoire le
seul qui est au courant de la faire
c'est nicolas donc qui est un ami à un
ami de l'uci qui est jouée par stomy
bugzy voilà alors le rôle des deux
jumelles est interprétée par marion
cotillard patrick bruel il fait très
bien d'ailleurs le patron d'une maison
de disques ophélie vous êtes une égérie
de la nuit dans ce film on peut dire ça
j'ai pas comment tu me décrirais tu as
et un jeune noir en sait encore bien il
s'est tiré du livre de virginie
despentes
magnéto
six mois on avait beau se ressembler on
était très différente
un soir elle est partie pour toujours
suivi sur en lan
j'ai pris sa place
s'ils connaissaient pas le monde comme
si l intéressé personne sans qu on s'en
souvient mais tu crois que c'est si
facile de se faire passer pour quelqu'un
d'autre
maintenant sujets abordés gérant
diraient les lèvres des jeux tv annonce
là je sais pas je connais pas tu vois ce
pas si compliqué d'être conne ne rasera
pas les gens mais ton mec paumé j'ai
terriblement d'été pis les noms et
l'allemand tu veux te lausanne
pourquoi tu vas chanter qu'est ce qui te
motive une crique
c'est sa voix qui compte mais que c'est
sa voix
tu passes ton temps à fermer ma gueule
de losail qui t'intéresse pas vrai
battue continue à fermer ta gueule
[Musique]
tu veux faire quand même ce jusqu'au
bout tu vas faire quand même je suis
fier de toi
ménard en garde toi
et que tu connais mon
les jolies choses
pas pour les petits tripoli
neel oui tout ça c'est du vent et toi
tes rêves du vent senin broc métier de
nageurs c'est plus que ça traite en toi
pour ton pas les jolies choses c'est
qu'autre chose les choses
m
c'est un ville une grande inventivité
sur le plan formel c'est très très rare
en france d'avoir des films aussi
sophistiquée sur le plan visuel non
ouais mais en même temps il ya une lame
de fond là qu'est en train d'arriver
vont enfin il ya ceux qu'on connaît
jan kounen mathieu kassovitz christophe
gornès moi je pense que je fais un peu
partie de la deuxième génération de ce
que j'appelle les réalisateurs cinéphage
et cinéphiles c'est à dire qu'ils ont
été élevés au cinéma américain et aussi
au cinéma français contre l'assurance de
sauter aussi dans les salles de bistrot
en fait donc une évidence et que l'on a
grandi avec stallone phare sénégal etc
et puis par ce biais là on est arrivé à
un cinéma un peu plus pointu et voilà
mais j'ai pas fait d'école j'ai pas fait
tout ça quoi c est un moyen métrage qui
s'appelait le marquis un qui avait déjà
eu pas mal de succès qui avait été très
remarquée et dans le film la chance que
vous avez c'est que tous les acteurs
sont à participation parce qu'il croyait
au projet oui enfin le marquis c'est un
peu une histoire de fou c'est un truc
que je me suis levé un matin j'ai dit
dans quinze jours on va faire un film et
en traitant ya patrick bruel sony
béziers qui se sont trouvés dedans mais
wayne le besco vanessa des moules et
puis des amis à moi tony amani matthew
bull et mais là je suis en train de le
remonter
et pour pour le ressortir après je pense
directement en vidéo et ce qui est bien
c'est que ça m'a permis de bach on se
rend compte tout ce qu'on commence à
travailler ensemble et pouvoir
poursuivre après sur les jolies choses
alors à une semaine du tournage vous
aviez toujours pas d'actrice pour
interpréter votre ange noir
pourquoi vous avez choisi ophélie
finalement j'ai un peu forcé en fait moi
j'ai un copain qui m'appelle j'étais à
saint tropez où je puis vous écumez il
ya un rôle super pour toi il faut que tu
appelles les metteurs en scène donc
j'appelle gilles une demande est remonté
à parler au monde d'art bas et je le
supplie de me prendre pour faire ce rôle
parce que c'était un rôle très trash et
que j'avais envie de faire un truc comme
ça pour changer enfin et j'ai un petit
peu j'ai un peut violer c'est ce que
j'aime bien dire ça mais c'est vrai il
disait tout le temps je voudrais une
sorte de félines winter large volet
quelqu'un qui le dit pourquoi tu prends
pas ophélie winter tout simplement
et voilà ça fait la blague il ya la
vraie ophélie dans son film à une
chanson du film que vachement bien
m
[Musique]
500 d'accès l'or noir très belle très
belle chanson qui va être un tube en
plus non c'est bien
alors fini c'est la forme mais je vais
déclarer vous avez déclaré le plus
difficile dans ce métier c'est de durer
j'étais tellement jeunes au départ et
puis il a fallu que je réalise ce qui
m'arrivait ensuite tout s'emballe et ça
peut être violent ouais
et c'est vrai que pour vous tout s'est
mis en marche en même temps la musique
la télévision c'était ça a été très
rapide et très violent non c'est parti
en flammes
c'est un peu à cause de vous en même
temps je préfère me le dire les gens ne
le savent pas mais j'avais fait une
émission je mets mes dents longues dans
le jury a on vous voit vous aviez mis
dans le jury d'une émission que vous
produisiez et dont quelques uns de m6
m'a remarqué ce jour là et m'a proposé
d'autres émissions et après tout est
parti comme ça et c'est vrai que j'ai
fait un break les deux dernières années
et que c'est pendant ces deux dernières
années que j'ai réalisé ce qui m'était
arrivé on va voir l'émission on parlait
titre peut-être qu'on trouvera un
détient classé dans ce classement dans
une dizaine d'années un lien elle fait
lit tu nous prépares un top 10 - mais
des simples pour l'instant des 45 ans
est un album en préparation aux frères
mammouth sentir en outre à août est-ce
que évidemment comme c'est prévu on aura
quelques titres de prins dessus il
n'aura pas 40 12 il y en aura deux
voire trois bon d'accord et pour la
rentrée j'ai appris qu'à priori tu
devais peut-être chanter un peu au
zénith en première partie de certains
artistes
pour l'instant on va voir si c'était la
première apparition de pedro winter et à
la télévision
elle avait été choisie pour 1,3 dans le
jury effectivement de la coupe du monde
de la séduction à la comédie la
séduction et puis voilà et c'est laurent
ce petit sur m6 qui vous avec vous a
remarqué et qui a décidé de vous faire
faire date et l'heure tout a démarré en
même temps il y avait l'album il y avait
là il y avait la télé c'était très
rapide ça a été ça a été fou et c'était
un peu dépassé par les événements
pendant un mois aux deux équipes rendent
un peu le melon et après je me suis
retombée c'est un pied très speed vous
étiez surmédiatisé un moment on peut le
dire moi c'était un peu et je fais si
vous vous souvenez quand on était petits
y avait des bouquins qui s'appelait
martine à la plage du ski j'avais un peu
l'impression d'être martin dans la
presse georges n'importe-quoi ophélie au
monoprix ophélie fait tout ce qu'il a
fait n'importe quoi wen jiabao ophélie
au revoir on va parler de votre vie
oui
alors vous êtes né en 1974 est la fille
du chanteur hollandais david alexandre
winter et de kathy winters mannequin
l'époque et qui est aujourd'hui votre
agent correct aux parents se séparent
quand vous avez deux ans et vous allez
vivre donc en france arrivée en france
et vivra neuilly et votre père s'en va
habiter aux usa et vous dit en parlant
de lui qu'il était lobotomisés du coeur
ah oui parce qu'en fait j'ai compris
super tard en fait quand mon grand père
est juste avant que mon grand père s'en
aille
enfin m eur sur son lit d'hôpital il m'a
raconté un truc est parce qu on est juif
donc et dans la famille quand l'aller
les nazis sont arrivés en hollande mais
mes grands parents ont placé mon père
dans une famille catholique et plus les
nazis se rapprochait plus les familles
passé mon père de famille en famille
comme ça donc il a dû faire cinq ou six
familles et du coup il a recréé ça quand
il a été adulé il fait des gosses
partout je découvre des frères des
soeurs hollande en belgique c'est
n'importe quoi s'est il a été très
généreux de sa graine mon papa c'est
votre mère qui vous avez levé 4 6 donc
prennent d'argent quand vous étiez
enfant je me souviens de trucs le pire
dont je me souvienne c'est quand on
était à l'école en loin on avait un
appartement et on le louer pendant qu'on
était à l'école on aller habiter chez
des copains pour que ma mère est un peu
d'argent pour nous au fil et à manger
donc c'est assez souvent les les pâtes
et les patates ah ouais parfois manger
de la viande c'était la fête
mais bon ma mère a assuré
bien assurée et malgré tout vous avez
quand même le sens du du spectacle
chevillée au corps parce que vous faites
votre premier disque à l'âge de 6 ans
aux ménages étaient pas consciente à la
mer qui est je voulais chanter donc elle
me déguiser et faire ce truc là et
j'étais super en colère après elle mais
on a récidivé à l'âge de 12 ans et là
j'ai dit ça suffit je tous mes copains
l'école c'est bon j'ai dit à tous mes
potes on verrai quand je serai grande ça
m'a mis la rage du quand je serai grand
je serai un indice que ça marchera ya
des cols situés assez dur quand vous
étiez petit
oui mais c'est pas beau oppose pour dix
balles vous arranger les affaires de
beaux de vos camarades d'école j'ai en
fait j'étais grande en sais quoi
maintenant peu maternelle en primaire
j'étais assez grande par rapport aux
autres jeux casser la gueule pour d'y
prendre aux toilettes je faisais des
spectacles
j'arrive à l'écran de mes copines et
après je ça s'est retourné contre moi
parce qu'au lycée j'étais naine pendant
trois ans je me sens et 40
et là c'était plutôt mois pour le tabac
c'est la plus petite de la classe et
c'est un petit peu une métaphore de
votre vie parce que finalement tout le
monde va vers vous et puis après vous
vous retrouvez un peu là c'est ce qui
vient de se passer pendant deux trois
ans vous retrouvez un peu la naine de la
classe mais c'est plus c'est bien ça
fait du bien de se prendre une petite
claque dans la tronche comme ça en
devient bien je te montre il vous pouvez
votre revanche à l'époque où les grandes
gigues ne sont plus à la mode et c'est
la fin dès la fin des plates et vous
avait contraint exact ça m'a sauvé la
vie ça j'ai commencé à être mannequin
cette époque là je partis de chez ma
mère à la tchipa j'avais 17 ans jugent
est mannequin et un petit peu rigoler
parce que sa tâche par un mètre 68 et
j'avais des saints triple de jeux
récents de tour de poitrine c'est vrai
ça n'arrivait d'un coup en plus jusqu'à
17 ans j'étais comme la table mais c'est
vrai c'est super
rollon sur la plage voilà fatwa toi toi
je vais t'attraper je dis ça peut
prendre des années et non sens quand
même
alors à neuilly sur le même palier que
vous habitez les frères mc h
eliana qui vous dit vous avez un
physique de chanteuse c'est les phrases
de films satisfaire des chapeaux et non
pas encore et oui donc le comité c'était
mon voisin et que je voyais sortir son
chien depuis des années je pensais que
c'était quelqu'un de bien donc j'ai
commencé à travailler avec lui et ses
frères s'est avéré que ça c'est pas
super bien passé donc j'ai fait un
divorce de producteurs qui a duré un an
et qui m'a empêché de chanter pendant un
an
non non ce n'est pas chanter vous avez
profité pour faire de la télé sur m6
mais en expliquant quand même à qui
voulait l'entendre que ce n'était pas le
but de votre vie expliqué justin un
passage c'est l'époque aussi de votre
relation avec prins alors on n'a jamais
su ce qui s'est passé parce qu'un jour
je vous ai posé la question dans un
journal et vous m'avez dit le premier
qui parle doit payer chez plus combien
1000 $ à l'autre c'est pas ouais ouais
j'avais une petite amourette avec 13 il
ya prescription maintenant si on peut en
parler foot oui c'est fini
ouais les nombreux voyages à minneapolis
entre mais c'était j'ai décidé de
refaire la téloche toi j'étais encore à
l'école j'avais 17 ans j'étais encore à
l'école
ouais ça commençait vachement tôt il le
vendredi soir quand j'ai quitté l'école
je prenais l'avion je faisais paris
boston boston minneapolis et j'en
revenais le dimanche inutile de dire que
les devoirs et les courges n'importe
quoi que ce soit ça a duré longtemps ça
l'aventuré galabru t'aurais pas
redoublés non plus
et après ça
j
la mois
c'est quoi
g
ok
alors ça c'était en fait mon 4e essai
discographique et 8,3 échec avant et
c'est génial parce que vous dites
finalement au point où j'en suis
maintenant je me suis tellement planter
autant faire ce qui me plaît
glorifier dieu voilà c'est l'idée que
vous aviez et dieu vous a aidé
apparemment aide toi le ciel t'aidera un
truc comme ça j'ai pas mais j'avais
vraiment une parler de ça je me suis
toute façon personne ça n'intéresse
personne dieu mes copains quand je leur
ai fait lire ma chanson homonyme et
attend les n'importe quoi et finalement
voilà c'était la belle surprise et alors
là c'est un peu le début du délire parce
que vous déclarez à l'issue de ce succès
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être
prédestiné bon jusque là d'avoir une
boule de feu au dessus de la tête
oui elle à l'époque j'avais un peu de
mal à m'exprimer donc non mais très gêné
pas une boule de feu mais j'avais fini
je peux pas en parler là mais qu'est ce
qui s'était passé j'ai fait une séance
d'hypnose une fois pour arrêter de fumer
et c'est à dire écrire ça va pas marcher
ça peut marcher mais c'est tant mieux et
j'ai une image comme ça de jeu voyez les
gens comme des boules de feu c'était en
fait c'étaient les âmes qui étaient
comme des petites boules de feu qui
parlaient en faisant de la télépathie
fin j'en avais l'impression au moment où
vous aviez aucune maîtrise de votre
carrière si on faisait un petit peu tout
ce qu'on vous demandez où j'ai des choix
assez aléatoire n'est pas connue et en
rêve depuis que tu es petit tu fais
n'importe quoi j'ai dit à une fois que
j'aurais pu faire une ouverture de
prisunic avec un string panthère
j'aurais fait n'importe quoi pour être
connu ce que j'en rêvais et comme ça un
peu marcher je me suis dit ma mère me
disait tout le temps tu profites profite
parce que ça peut très bien s'arrêter
demain
ouais je me disais de [ __ ] [ __ ] vite
oui alors oui à toi oui je vous retrouve
à dire oui à tout le monde à faire des
trucs qui n'avait ni queue ni tête
ce que je ne sais plus aujourd'hui et
cette histoire avec mc solaar s'est
terminé comme en voit comme une rupture
de gens normaux c'est une éruption faire
ouais normal kouakou l'avion avec en
même temps cinq ans et demi
adam koné winter comme vous êtes
croyante on va vous faire une interview
croyance en a beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe et j'en passe et
j'en remercie ma fille sur ce gros
déconne c'est parfait si tu as la parole
d'accord c'est à dire pas encore
s'exprimer
[Applaudissements]
bien
à l'interview croyances ophélie winter
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui oui oui la sacem
vous étiez enfant au lieu de vous créer
une espèce de vies parallèles comme font
les enfants avec des personnages et où
vous souhaitez dieu ouais ouais moi
c'est en fait j'ai compris encore plus
tard que c'était le manque de pair et
qu'en fait on lui parlé à mon père je
parlais à dieu tous les mois j'avais
besoin d'un homme dans ma vie voilà
est-ce que vous croyez à l'amour oui oui
j'y crois encore ouais vous avez été
assez tardive parce que votre premier
garçon où il avait connu dont vous aviez
dit cette année où les relations
sexuelles oui oui je n'étais pas j'étais
un mec j'étais vachement mec je serai
mais avec moi c'est un frère ouais tu
vois que tu es filles fassent savoir à
quel âge non ce n'est pas prête à
l'emploi
j'avais pas de sens jusqu'à 17 ans quant
à ben voilà j'avais pas le matos je vous
cherchez un père pour un bébé je cherche
un père veut même un homme pour moi
d'abord cela les arrange personne et
après éventuellement vous dites il faut
quelqu'un qui m'aime pour mon âme et pas
seulement pour mon physique parce que
dans 20 ans j'ai le cul par terre et je
fais des nues avec mes seins c'est vrai
que c'est pas très encourageant mais
c'est dur à trouver un mec je suis
paranoïaque c'est avec les mecs j'ai
l'impression que le jour je vais être
enceinte ils vont aller sauter à droite
à gauche
je sais pas ce qui va se passer cherchez
quoi comme genre de mec j'ai pas que
jean mec avec qui je me marre qu'ils
soient gentils qui m'aime moi si tu vois
tout le monde peut poser sa candidature
mais voilà vous avez le site de tout
prendre en parle sur france 2 c'est
pourtant la question de la fiche numéro
69 c'est vous qui me poser une question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 questions thierry hocquet projet moi
une question est-ce que tu m'aimes
c'est pas du tout
gilles carrez s'est pas mêlé
j'aurais pu l'être en à vérité c'est que
j'aurais aimé être ton pygmalion on en
parlera est ce que vous croyez en vous
maintenant oui depuis peu ouais je vous
coller aux anges gardiens ouais c'est
pas vraiment de gardien c'est en fait en
fait c'est un autre un autre nous dans
un espèce de l'univers parallèle moi
c'est comme ça aux fantômes
ouais un superman non non non au père
noël non plus maintenant au pouvoir de
pikachu
ouais alors vous voyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
non mais j'espère et je me plais à y
croire jean de placebo sharma que ça
marche la réincarnation vous y croyez
oui voudraient vous réincarner en quoi
vos achats pour être caressé bouffer
dormir je vous croyais à céline dion et
alors tu as d'autres questions non mais
c'est joker c'est cgil qui raconte oui
quand on répond pas ça passe à la
personne d'à côté c'est ainsi je dis non
à ma première télé je crois penser d'une
jauge a l'air con quand même si tu dis
oui aussi
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
presley
oui oui parce qu'il a éclaté sur les
chiottes enfin qu'il prenait tellement
de cachet de gens pour dormir pour
manger pour maigrir pour l'un qu'il a
éclaté je suis convié la fidélité dans
le couple et g non maintenant moi oui
j'essaie d'être je suis fidèle à laurent
blanc je te jure c'est l'allemagne
est ce vous voyez à l'amour son sexe non
non quand on aime il faut que ça vous
croyez au sexe sans amour
ouais bien sûr est ce que voudrait que
patrick fiori peut se remettre de son
aventure avec lara fabian y avoir dit
trop dur c'est trop loin car il est vrai
qu'on peut faire l'amour cinq fois de
suite
ah oui je confie le garçon là un faux
candidats non je pense
et je sais
[Applaudissements]
j'ai attaqué
alors quelques emails avant de continuer
christophe de méricourt qui dit ma femme
et moi on fait souvent l'amour devant
ton émission
pourrais tu lui dire que la fellation
est une chose naturelle dans le couple
j'aurais peut-être une chance grâce à
toi non c'est pas un truc naturel la
relation
c'est un truc contre nature autre email
thierry si tu passes ce message en
mentionnant mon prénom est ma ville elle
me fait la totale ben non
j'accueille maintenant valérie lemercier
marie
à
mercier ça va pas mal
est ce que pour vous la fellation est
une chose naturelle dans le groupe je ne
sais pas ce que c'est c'est bien ce que
je disais c'est la nature telle attaque
bille en tête bille en tête
et voilà alors vous êtes déjà venu dans
cette émission nous raconter votre vie
la drogue la prostitution
ils ont fini on va pas recommencer à
chaque fois j'ai simplement rappeler un
petit peu votre passé qui est brillant
mais elle avait le mercier vous avez
grandi à gonfreville en seine-maritime
avec trois soeurs départ en exploitant
agricole à 18 ans vous monter à paris
vous fait le conservatoire et puis les
petits boulots comme vendeuse aux
galeries lafayette nous a beaucoup aidés
par la suite pour caricaturer les gens
vous débutez au piano zinc un bar
homosexuel du marais et puis vous
commencez à faire des one man show de la
télévision du cinéma pour un premier one
man show vous obtenez un molière en
télévision ou fait lady palace dans la
série de jean michel ribes au cinéma
milou en mai avec louis malle les
visiteurs le numéro un où vous obtenez
un césar du meilleur second rôle
vous refusez le second mais vous faites
un album avec bertrand burgalat et
ensuite vous commencez à réaliser des
films de pub les puits des films de
cinéma dont le génial le derrière qui
caricaturent la gauche caviar gay et là
vous obtenez pour troisième one man show
une récompense qui est encore un molière
voilà
fillon
c'est l'apaisement
à ses enfants
bien où en sont vos rapports avec la
promotion à la télévision ça va je suis
là vous dites on ne pose jamais les
bonnes questions
non il ya des mauvaises surtout peut-on
rire de tout ouais du bien de rien avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est la
troisième guerre mondiale j'ai vu un
alors donc vous êtes ici pour votre
troisième one man show celui qui a été
pendant six mois aux folies bergères et
qui maintenant part en tournée en
province avec un olympia l'olympia c'est
du 11 au 15 décembre et la tournée c'est
dans toute la france jusqu'en mars 2002
il ya en tournée en ce moment ouais
c'est comment on fait avec les mains je
sais pas fait
6 novembre à clermont-ferrand dans le 63
le 8 à vichy sait dans quoi vichy je ne
sais pas le 9 à nevers dans le quoi à 9
heures à 9 heures le 10 à bourges à
bourges
je vais être bouge chez les bourgeois et
après en belgique en belgique bien sûr à
liège à bruxelles
voilà mais on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble ma les deux équipes en mal
mais ça tu l'entends pas en
reconnaissant les rails
je m'appelle sont bien coûter j'ai 19
ans je suis élève dans une école de
tourisme j'ai inscrit ne cherche un
stage dans les milieux
non mais ça n'enlève aussi de m'amuser à
un merci je sais ce que c'est avec
l'humour je pratique s'est produit vers
et à droite beaucoup
je suis un pro charge avant ce que tu
sais si c'est vrai que juliette c'est
juliette juliette de roméo et juliette
en fait elle aime pas romeo non parce
que la grande peur de ma copine daphné
elle dit qu'en fait elle fait l'amour
avec le chanteur d'ali baba
je me donne à fond
[Musique]
outre un certain éclat
les 11 et 12 décembre ça marche alors
vous en foutez vous avez pas besoin de
faire de la promo très bien je suis très
contente d'être parti en tournée très
contente et c'est tout ce que je déteste
d'habitude on voit des coui c'est tout
ce que c'était simplement il ya un tel
décalage c'est à dire que on a tellement
pas d'image qui ont fini par passer des
trucs où je suis en train de doubler
tarzan ou comme ça que c'est d'ailleurs
très mauvaise qualité ce qu'on vient de
voir c'est juste mon petit caméscope qui
a filmé un soir aux folies bergères donc
j'en ai assez des petits vous mais c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya pas de cassettes n'y a
pas de le spectacle n'est pas filmé oui
c'est ça ça vous fait jamais de
cassettes de vos spectacles y aura pas
de trace non il y en a 2 aucun des trois
camps vous serez mort tu vois plus rien
voilà il y aura plus rien à ok voilà
c'est ça ouais c'est la vie alors c'est
un spectacle est très au point des
textes très ciselée très très juste
autour d'une douzaine de personnages qui
ont tous un point commun c'est d'être
des victimes on peut dire non un peu oui
un petit peu un petit peu mal barré il
ya le personnage typique lemercier la
burj catho qui ramassent des cormorans
mazoutés capelle sa soeur bene s'asseoit
label inouïe ouais bah bill ça c'est un
classique
oui c'est à dire que j'avais pas fait
dans le précédent de bourges comme ça
mais là je les reprises ça m'amusait de
la mettre dans un autre contexte de la m
en bretagne c'est surtout qu'elle a une
soeur qui est très dépressive et qu'elle
est très méchant dont il ya une vieille
défoncer des fois c'est jouer non non il
l'a droguée où elle est assez javanais
les allées c'est fait stériliser en
avril 95 par ses parents mais bon elle
est mal barré aussi une paysanne une
prof de danse russe une étudiante très
méchante et puis des passages en sprint
comme on vient de voir la belle aux
normes le belge veuve qui raconte de son
fils comment sa mère était bonne ouais
ouais nférieure ça les gens jeunes à
mais c'est à dire que c'est très drôle
d'ailleurs parce que je suis en tournée
depuis un mois plus je suis dans le nord
plus ça parle aux gens c'est à dire
carrément via des gens j'ai joué à
maubeuge l'autre jour c'est vrai que les
gens sont très près de lamu la belgique
dans toutes les expressions beige
donc j'ai hâte de le jouer à bruxelles
en forme belgique
vous n'êtes toujours pas mariés vous non
plus non c'est les deux mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez des fils et plus de mecs
non c'est vrai ya plus de cinq ans casey
les biens il reste que les bars à thème
dans l'aisne nous marquons vous avez
perdez jamais vous marier mais s'ils
aimeraient bien mais je sais pas fini
ouais voulait lancer un appel la télé
non pas du tout non surtout pas non
c'est sûr parce que vous savez comment
ça marche soit des nombreux royaumes et
je vais non mais c'est bon aussi j'ai
reçu une lettre aujourd'hui on me
demandait des photos avec des tas de
tenues différentes
ce que vous pouvez mettre des tables
tenues différentes et m'envoyer les
photos non non mais je fais pas
d'alliance maintenant on fait des non
plus non ça va ça va venir tous à tenir
tout seul
et maintenant
ah bon
voici pour butt
très bon soir ça champion du monde 98
vainqueur de l'euro 2000 capitaine de
l'om et vous avez déclaré dans france
football
je refuse toutes les émissions de
télévision sauf celle de thierry
ardisson
vous êtes la meilleure donc c'est normal
vous avez le crâne rasé c'est pas de la
coquetterie
ah non c'est parce que vous avez
commencé à perdre ses cheveux à 28 ans
vous avez perdu vos cheveux à l'âge de
28 ans 1
maintenant j'ai commencé plus tôt ma
main à 21 22 ans ah ouais c'était
surtout par nécessité que je me suis
rasé la tête mais quand j'ai fait au
départ on a cru que j'étais malade et
donc n'étaient pas tendance à l'époque
mais il dit maintenant c'est fashion
avait pas que tout le monde croyait que
j'étais leucémiques mais il y en a
encore pour qui malheureusement c'est
pas une mode d'autres choses
[Musique]
c
non
m
[Musique]
pour lutter les informer soutenir aux
malades
la ligue contre le cancer
[Applaudissements]
spot donc pour la ligue contre le cancer
c'est là près crozemarie donc les gens
essayent de redemander de l'argent
français après ce qui s'est passé
heureusement que vous êtes là il faut
vraiment des champions du monde parce
que non mais ces gens qui plaçaient
tellement odieux
ouais sinon c'est vrai que c'était
odieux et c'est vrai que ça beaucoup de
gens se sont posé des questions mais je
pense que la ligue contre le cancer a
vraiment envie de redonner un coup de
boost à a à la pelle dé notamment de fin
de l'argent quoi et séries c'était
important de le faire parce que on a
banalisé cette maladie on a observé
qu'on a beaucoup parlé du sida et
notamment et que on oublie un petit peu
le cancer et qu'il faut surtout pas
oublier que c'est quand même la maladie
qui tue le plus de personnes et que
c'est important de le faire moi ça m'a
touché ça me touche encore plus parce
que dans ma famille je l'avais grand
père qui est mort du cancer beau-père
qui insiste bertrand depuis quatre ans
qui va sortir l'hôpital parce que ben ça
va ça va un peu mieux et c'est vrai que
ça ça me touche et que je suis tous les
jours à l'hôpital et que j'en vois tous
les jours qui souffrent et c'était bien
de le faire mais c'était pas seulement
pour mon père c'était pour tout le monde
et je pense qu'il faut aussi bien que
fabien et nicolas et appuyer cette thèse
on va revenir au football j'ai vu le
maire à la télévision complètement
effondrée parce que les clubs étrangers
dans lesquels jouent les français
veulent pas les laisser aller jouer en
équipe de france
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il ya
un match en australie là
la semaine prochaine et que on se doit
de présent puisque là le sélectionneur
et la fédération française font appel à
nous et ça gêne certains certains clubs
parce que notamment arsenal puisque
c'est arsène wenger qui est qui avait
commencé cette cette polémique qui est
devenue une pétition
auprès des clubs de tous les clubs ou
auxquelles appartiennent les joueurs en
équipe de france
mais gérer que nous on n'a pas tellement
notre mot à dire il n'y a pas une règle
de la fifa qui oblige les clubs
étrangers à rendre les joueurs nationaux
1,6 à l'équipe de france pour les
matches intéressants complètement là le
droit à huit matches dans la saison avec
l'équipe de france c'est donc sur celui
ci sera le dernier et le 8e et le
dernier et c'est vrai que beaucoup de
clubs ont notamment arsenal ils ont la
ligue des champions le championnat juste
les coupes nationales et donc pour
certains les joueurs l'équipe de france
et ça pose problème mais bon on veut
c'est un choix du sélectionneur c'est
aujourd'hui c'est toujours pour nous je
pense à la douleur des sans équipe de
france donc on ne peut pas trop non plus
râler quand on doit aller ou l autre
coin du monde bien sûr alors on va
parler du match france algérie où la
marseillaise a été sifflé ou le stade a
été envahi vous vous aviez été remplacé
à la pause par mikaël silvestre et vous
êtes retourné sur le stade d'un costume
cravate et en boitant et vous avez
gueuler quand même fait partie de ce
congolais
vous dites on vous fait prendre des
risques pour des raisons politiques pour
montrer nos bonnes relations et nous
envie de de retrouver certaines amour
avec avec les algériens on avait
organisé ce match mais moi j'ai pas
critiquer le fait d'avoir ce match au
contraire c'était bien de le faire mais
c'était certainement pas le moment quoi
après le 11 septembre les attentats
terroristes y avait trop de symbole
sur le terrain réunis et on en a fait
vraiment une affaire politique et donc
aux saveurs moi je m'attendais dès jeudi
puisque le match a eu lieu le samedi à
ce qui nous arrive un problème beaucoup
plus grave que ce qui est arrivé est
donc samassa moi ça m'a gêné je les dis
après après trois jours de réflexion je
les dis
je pense que ce match avait pas lieu
d'être et surtout que l'organisation
n'ait été complètement inexistante
on a retrouvé des piques en bois sur le
terrain et qui aurait suffi qu'un qatari
rentrer sur le terrain et enfonce le pic
en bois sur l'île en tueur a par exemple
été le dernier à sortir mais tout le
monde est rentré donc vous d'ailleurs et
thuram est resté là thuram est resté
ouais ils sont restés il ya quelqu'un
qui sont restés coûts qui ont compensé
qui avait pas de problème mais c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas
il n'y a pas eu de problème mais il
aurait pu en avoir un et on serait
peut-être en train de plus rien des
joueurs l'équipe de france à l'heure
actuelle
donc c'est vrai que moi j'ai aussi
ressenti ça comme
dans une insécurité totale en tout cas
et j'ai un moment donné a fait chaud au
coeur parce que psychologiquement
j'étais atteinte par un parent par
partout ça que j'avais ma femme était à
paris avec les enfants j'avais dit vous
y allez pas vous allez pour match et que
j'avais senti qu'il y avait il ya les
avoir un problème j'ai pensé que madame
buffet était et est responsable de tout
ça et qu'elle devait être tenu comme
responsable
vous avez vu ce match chauffer les noms
pensez quoi
j'ai trouvé ça nul ce n'est pas le
moment de faire ce genre de connerie n'a
pas de leur part je ne sais vraiment
qu'on mélange est justement comme tu me
dis là comme vous le dites si bien le
sport et maman est là et la politique
c'est vraiment bien mais c'est en plus
le match était un beau match lens était
content de l'arrêter à ce que j'ai près
de la fin quoi rêvez-vous non car
j'aimais le foot
ah bon vous regardez pas le foot non
pour ça que vous avez pas vous marier
non mais attendez
les mêmes ce qu'ils veulent c'est la
jeune femme qui regarde le foot je vous
le dis moi voilà en tous les cas des
années quand même je suis heureux je
suis allé à la finale de coupe du monde
il y avait des types oeil maquillé en
bleu blanc rouge comme ça qu'ils aient
fait la bise j'étais tout maquillé en
bleu blanc rouge
vous avez vu franck alors oui j'ai vu
franck bien sûr c'est comme ça que je
connais bien caen jasse pas en tant qu
on siffle la marseillaise et qui
quittent pas le stade ça vous fait quel
effet vous moi le fait que l'on soit
sifflé
je m'y attendais je veux dire que dans
le monde du football
le respect jerry d'une nation où le
respect des joueurs simplement des
individus n'existe pas je suis rentré en
france
j'ai quand j'étais dedans quand j'étais
en angleterre on me disait souvent mais
pourquoi les champions du monde revienne
pas en france ce serait bien qu'il
vienne et je reviens est tous contents
et c'est vrai que je vais sur certains
stades et j'entends mon nom suivi d'un
an d'oiseaux quoi ex-amant d'oiseaux
ouais donc c'est vrai de se faire
traiter de
d'enculés il faut le dire sur un terrain
de football
c'est vrai j'ai ça méritait rien fait je
pense que quand on a un respect quand on
joue au golf quand j'ai au golf de jouer
au tennis il
ça ne vous traite d'enculé bizarrement
alors que alors que
je suis passé non mais voilà donc c'est
dommage parce que bon c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas que des intelligences serein dans
un terrain de sur un terrain de football
et dans les tribunes et que c'est
dommage de se faire traiter comme ça
quand on est bon enfant les ces gens là
ont fait ça c'est vrai bon on va passer
à l'om
bon alors le 20 octobre
bah vous étiez suspendu pour om lille
suite à l'incident qui avait eu le 13
octobre sur m om les mauvais caractère
je suis pas facile mais non je pense pas
avoir mûri caractère surtout sur ce coup
là où je suis copain oui j'ai pas fait
une faute du match seul joueur ça va
être le seul joueur dans le monde à se
faire expulser sans avoir commis une
seule faute pendant tout le match c'est
quand même assez rigolo ouais enfin bon
faut accepter l'issue de l'arbitrage est
un peu soupe au lait quand même c'est
vraiment très certainement à strasbourg
par exemple je sais pas mais vous aviez
sorti un journaliste de l'équipe des
vestiaires à coup de genou dans le
ventre et quand on vous ai demandé
pourquoi à coup de genou dans le ventre
de vie parce que j'ai la cheville
bousillé je ne fais jamais rien géré
pour rien il m'a il m'a
la part et il n'a pas traité de reculer
mais il m'a cassé et m'a cassé pendant
une année
l'année de la qualification +96 quand je
suis en équipe de france
et puis bon on m'avait demandé nos
instances fédérales de pas bouger
donc j'ai pas bougé jusqu'au moment où
on a été comme ça on s'est qualifiés et
à ce moment-là bombe sa valeur un coeur
elle est venue elle est venue j'avais
demandé par entrer j'avais été gentilles
avait prévenu demandez pas rentrer mais
il arrive aussi un coup de boule les
foules
voilà brésil felix battue que je réalise
non non ça ne mérite pas trop fait
parler les journalistes qui ne surtout
pas bien méchant joue c'est tellement
nul que je ne préfère pas répondre ouais
jamais de football je vais tout jaloux
dans le ventre non mais c'est la boxe
thaï samassa me défouler un sac de
frappe sur ma terrasse je suis énervé je
vais mettre des petits coups et après je
redescends moi j'aimerais bien mais j'ai
pas de terrasse
moi je viens l'hôtel pour l'instant à
envoyer des données des hôtels comptent
maintenant je peux pas me les payer
français vous souffrez pas d'un manque
de confiance en vos connaissances
d'argent chambre d'hôtel est qu'une plus
large en attendant il a souffert à une
époque sur l'argent on va en parler
maintenant cela non mais c'est vrai que
vous ressentez un peu tout et critiques
comme les agressions non non mais je
pense que moi j'ai mon
on m'a critiqué on a raison une chance
je suis pas bon c'est à dire c'est pas
c'est pas un problème mais je pense
qu'il ya des critiques sont pas fondés à
demander ça me ça m'énerve c'est vrai
quand on m'a qualifié de personnes
antenne de qui elle qui avait la grosse
mer grosse tête on a dit c'est vrai la
grossesse est vrai c'est vrai alors que
quand on vous voit rire à la trêve mais
fuir mais mais non mais si le problème
bon le problème il est là mais c'est pas
trés c'est pas très grave en soi mais
sur x non un manque de reconnaissance
non dites moi alors marseille
relégables en d2 là non bon normalement
quand même pas loin mais non pas loin
non mais bon on est en période difficile
c'est clair mais je pense que je pense
que ça va aller beaucoup mieux moi
j'espère et si marseille descendez de
vous rester ou non
moi je pense rester mais j'ai encore
deux ans de contrat je pense qu'il ya
j'ai toujours respecté j'ai toujours
fait des longs contrats et j'ai toujours
respecté le club
ok j'ai appartenu et métaux sont je suis
à agir et à 99% sûr que l'om descendra
pas cette année moi je vais jouer à
marseille
oui c'est pour moi un honneur et c'est
bien sûr j'ai pas sur un effet lemercier
à marseille n'y a pas eu à me dire qu'il
y en ait fait le buzz l'année crible non
mais
non mais c'est vrai que sinon ça s'est
très bien passé
et vous n'avez pas de terrasse à
marseille
tu m'a fait repenser commune
il a même
la pac terrasse à marseille mais je peux
te dire un truc c'est que en angleterre
il avait une belle maison 1 300 m il a
une maison de 300 m² d'ici piscine
intérieure trois étages ouais non mais
c'était bien c'était mais c'est un
investissement moi j'ai l'âge la
revendre donc la cua mais c'était juste
parce que pour toi car elle boucle à 6%
vous l'aviez acheté en plus cette barre
moi je l'avais acheté à une époque où
ou la livre montait où tout le monde m'a
dit mais tu es fou d'acheter et en fin
de compte j'espère bien la vente quoi
plutôt que de faire un loyer à loyers
sur exorbitants j'essaye déjà de vendre
la maison à l'école en septembre c'est
pas évident ça s'est passé en angleterre
ça stagne est un petit peu mais c'est
sûr qu'il est un saoudien en angleterre
et du showbiz un petit peu oui
ouais de victoria beckham qui va venir
tout à l'heure peut-être que paul
dewandre dit plus qu'à une terrasse avec
un poutine alors je vais faire un
reportage sur cette maison et ça n'avait
pas été très bon pour votre image
surtout en france avaient été très
mauvais mais il faut savoir reconnaître
ses erreurs c'était une grosse erreur
j'ai suivi un petit peu l'élan 98 tout
on a des champions du brandon il fallait
tout savoir sur eux et je t'es sympa
j'ai ouvert ma maison une femme des
enfants une maison une et c'est sale
c'est vraiment là et à la sortie c'est
bien sorti ça vient de tomber sur le nez
parce que bon c'est clair qu'il y avait
il y avait
la maison était grande il y avait une
piscine intérieure donc c'est vrai que
ça gênait les gérants il fallait que je
sois toujours pauvres mais serait me dit
quand même l'argent m'a fait flipper à
mort pas question de me retrouver plus
mais comme giresse non mais c'est à dire
que c'est pas le cas j'irai s'est fait
plumer parce qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
lui a piqué son argent ah ouais ouais je
connais pas les tenants être tous les
tenants et les aboutissants de son
histoire mais je sais que ça a été un
gros problème pour lui j'espère juste
faire attention problème c'est que on
est obligé quand même de faire confiance
à des financiers j'en ai trouvé un qui
me semble très très bien et et à qui je
fais a pratiquement totale confiance
mais
il faut toujours faire attention parce
que votre carrière est très courte et
que ben si déjà 34 ans vous parlez
d'arrêter oui c'est sûr que c'est oui je
vais arrêter parce que je veux pas être
ridicule sur un terrain qu'on ne dise
pas que bien après l'immobilier non non
ben je vais je vais commencer à prendre
des cours de théâtre parce que ça me
plait cour de floride et à l'argent donc
un genre ouais financièrement vous avez
un bon financier en qui la totale
confiance
nous avons quoi il investit votre argent
ouais dans des valeurs monétaires on a
beaucoup investi dans l'immobilier aussi
parce qu'on y croit j'ai quelques
appartements france en locatif donc
c'est sympa on katif aller dans les
cyclones et à toi mon blog c'est un mec
là bas les mariés en même temps mais la
mecque
mais c'est parce que moi je pensais le
marié avec ophélie et je me disais mais
pourquoi tous les deux et c'est par ici
ça fait des années ils sont connus à
l'école des très belles dents j'ai très
belles dents ouais c'est gentil ça
enfants comme le dit c'est bon c'est
vrai sans merci beaucoup à paul théâtre
vous êtes quand même très près de très
près du pognon je vous avais dit à un
journaliste du nouvel observateur vous
remarquez que je ne vous fais pas payer
l'interview deux heures d'interviews ces
deux heures de mon temps ouais c'est pas
sûr que j'ai eu une culture un petit peu
anglaise pendant cinq ans et que quand
je peux je
donner une interview à une télévision à
un temps de télévision en angleterre
j'étais payé et on vous êtes payé les
gens qui sont autour ils sont payés et
nous ne sommes pas payés rien du tout
bien sûr vous allez dans la meilleure
émission c'était un deuxième sac un
sapin sur sa terrasse et une terrasse
voilà y'a pas de problème mais novembre
ont fait passer pour un homme d'argent
je veux dire je vous dire la vérité en
fait vous avez ras mais vous en avez
souffert de l'argent parce que quand
vous avez été viré de toulon qui était
votre premier club peut t'arriver hameau
en 87 en d3 quelle étoile vous gagnez
500 francs par mois et voilà de quoi
acheter quatre pots de moutarde et y
disposer de 350 francs par semaine mais
pour faire à manger et le coca était
réservée aux amis bah ouais ben quand on
n'a pas d'argent il faut faire attention
c'est du belge envoie pas voilà de l'eau
du robinet est rhabillé faire attention
c'est pour ça que je fais attention à
l'argent on parle beaucoup d'argent mais
je fais attention à l'argent parce que
j'en ai manqué et que j'ai galéré que
j'ai envie que mes enfants ne visera
cette agence cet argent servira pour les
études mes enfants et moi si je finis
avec x 0 franc la fin de ma vie j'en à
foot voilà vous êtes intéressé par
l'argent parce que vous avez mangue est
exactement ce qu'il faut pas lui il va
leur laisser plein appartement c'est sûr
pendant vingt ans bien
lestrem alain leboeuf quand vous avez
quitté moselle chercher du boulot dans
un club
j'ai fait une petite cassette une petite
cassette vhs avec vos meilleurs au
meilleur moment vos meilleurs buts etc
et vous avez envoyé à laval et à auxerre
eq c'est laval qui a répondu le premier
qui aura été un peu plus lent sur le
coup et c'est trés vous en voulez
vraiment quoi les gens voulaient non
bien sûr ce n'était pas courant je les
fais parce que je voyais pas la fin du
tunnel et que j'étais en troisième
division et que mon envie c'était de
footballeur professionnel
voilà alors après lille strasbourg vous
avez ces fameux problèmes avec grèce à
l'horaire suisse trois ans de calvaire
avec lui quand même ouais trois ans de
calvaire mais si intime en main qui vous
disaient tu es un connard tu gagneras
jamais rien ouais c'est ce qui m'a dit
un jour
voilà je le remercie je l'en remercie il
sait motiver c'est bien mais je le
remercie parce qu'en fin de compte il va
donner envie de lui montrer qu'il avait
tort h oui
après chelsea dans quelle équipe de
fonsorbes chelsea quand même là ça
allait un million de francs par mois ça
va et on revient sur l'argent dans
l'équipe de france il ya eu ce problème
avec laurent blanc quoi n'y a pas eu de
problème vous allez répondre si vous
êtes là pour vous expliquer bien sûr
quand on faisait disputer la finale
contre le brésil à la place de laurent
blanc vous avez dit désolé pour loulou
mais ma joie est supérieur à ma peine
pour lui je serais pour mensonge dans
l'ensemble c'est à dire que j'ai fait
une conférence de presse la veille de la
finale de la coupe du monde et on m'a
parlé pendant trois quarts d'heure de la
suspension de laurent blanc je trouvais
ça dégueulasse qu'ils soient soient pas
qu'il ait pas jouer la finale parce
qu'ils méritaient de la jouer parce
qu'il m'a été surtout pas d'être expulsé
et c'est tout donc pendant au bout de
trois quarts d'heure les journalistes
ont de lui si vous étiez quand même
content très content j'ai joué en finale
de coupe du monde j'avais quand même pas
pleurer
les avis étaient remplaçants pendant
longtemps non mais il aurait fallu il
aurait fallu un moment de crise non je
peux pas jouer non pas c'est dégueu je
peux pas le faire je peux pas donc non
il aurait joué à dix on aurait mis
quelqu'un qui était pas à sa place
non donc j'ai décidé de jouer et c'est
vrai que j'ai passé quatre jours à 3
parce que je pouvais pas lui mais la
télévision je peux paillage journaux
parce que c'était comment on allait
faire sans l'eau l'eau que vous avez
jamais dit ça non jamais au contrat
c'était horrible
j'en ai dit quand on m'a dit à la fin du
match et à bilic celui qui a fait
expulser laurent blanc qui était monté
sur le dernier corner et leurs beats
siffle la fin et je me retourne il est
là il tombe dans mes bras et qu'ils
étaient d'accord est vrai que ce but je
l'avais payé pour faire expulser laurent
blanc qu'il faut arrêter c'est vraiment
dégueulasse quand je prendrai beaucoup
été arrêté
alors quand vous avez eu des hauts et
comme vous avez eu des bars interne
interview à peine d'arn franck leboeuf
on accouche pendant légal
[Musique]
oh
ce que vous préférez en vo qui joue mon
coeur votre bon coeur votre coeur
je pense que j'ai grand coeur ouais
ouais ce que vous haïssez en vous c'est
difficile à dire
comme si vous répondez pas c'est le
voisin qui répond c'est le principe doit
il s'est en effet dit je suis trop
bavard ouais bah oui moi aussi comme on
vient de le voir ce que vous préférez
dans le foot
non non parce que moi j'essaie d'éviter
que les gens remarquent début la
collectivité la collectivité c'est ce
qu'on appelait le collectif du temps
d'aimé jacquet voilà ouais pas de
personnel bon maintenant j'aime bien la
vie enfin la vie à un groupe
les échanges et le fit ce le fait de se
bouger pour un copain ne soient claires
fontaines la chaude ambiance tout ça ça
vous pourrez vous devriez venir j'écarte
monter la chaude ambiance pattes avant
pas du tout ce que vous détestez dans le
foot
la mauvaise presse ouais ouais les gens
qui font exprès de vous faire du mal
ils sont prêts à se flageller à la
télévision après une coupe du monde qui
le font jamais et qui sont capables de
vous dire qu'il n'avait pas fait ça vous
n'aurez pas gagné la coupe du monde 1 le
mec de l'équipe exact bureau jérôme
bureau et m'a dit son nom au bas ces dix
on nous fait le plus grand moment de
gris première fois que j'ai eu ma femme
quand je suis rentré dans le train c'est
vrai ça s'est passé comment raconter
nous parce que ça peut atteindre nos
amis je prenais le train l'été dans ce
train et javier doua ou louer tout
savoir oui j'allais de je prenais le
train à bandol quitte à bandol et
chalets sur toulon sur toulon et ma
femme était déjà dans le train était
monté sur l'a77 jolie demoiselle était
rentré dans le tralala la station
d'avant et je l' ai vu et je suis pas
fâché horaire mais je me suis mis
derrière moi et je voyais qu'avec sa
copine a parlé de moi donc j'ai dit il y
a il ya quelque chose de possible donc
c'est vrai que j'ai marché gelé suivi
tout enjeu pour savoir où aller où elle
allait ouais je savais j'avais parlé une
copine à elle est vue donc voilà qu'on a
essayé de vraiment on s'est perdus de
vue pendant deux mois et ils retrouvés
après encore dans dans le train puisque
je prenais le train tous les jours elle
aussi ses plans a commencé à se parler
de quoi et après donc voilà donc après
on s'est parlé ça a duré deux mois trois
mois
parler
je vais conclu assez vite après eux j'ai
conclu
non nous trois mois j'ai là j'ai réussi
à embrasser puis bout là pour conclure
il a fallu encore attendre c'est bon
d'accord elle était jeune pâtissier pour
conclure non quand même pas quand même
quand même pas mais toujours avec sp
combien d'années ça fait ça à faire 17
ans c'est beau ouais
le sais pas c'est difficile quand même
non non c'est pas difficile au contraire
c'est pas assez
c'est facile parce que elle est fascinée
parce que le pire moment de votre vie le
pire moment de ma vie je le vis en ce
moment avec les problèmes de mon père je
le vis en ce moment parce que c'est
c'est tous les jours c'est pas de pas de
répit et puis une amélioration mini mini
minimes tous les jours quand c'est pas
au contraire une descente aux enfers et
en ce moment c'est très très difficile
mais se faisait de plus sexy en vous
c'est pas faut demander aux valérie oui
pour vous fait lille a des yeux francs
et sexy jacuzzi de moins sexy
on est ici aussi ça mais c'est que s'ils
sont nés francs ouais ouais un peu trop
bien vite mais pourquoi aider les grands
très grands
ben alors voilà je compte aussi la
vaincre en est ah bon je veux
bon c'est déjà bien longtemps
attention ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe tout après tout où on sait que
c'est bon quand c'est bien fait c'est
bon c'est bon
ah ouais quand il disait ah ouais non
vous êtes une bonne affaire way à moi je
sais pas si mon affaire me faudrait
demander à mon épouse mes
ce qui vous dégoûte dans le sexe on ne
souffle pas photo philippe qui vous
dégoûte maso folie c'est tout je
comprends que ça fait 17 ans vous avez
avec des poneys
et maintenant la schl umich qui lie la
chambre
le jury
le plus
voici jean yanne
comment ça va il ya des moments on
croirait commémore pas la dernière fois
vous êtes venu il ya quoi il ya un an
non pour un livre déjà un
on a tout raconté les gens à part
commencer un vari je fasse ça tout de
suite pour me [ __ ] la paix non non les
le fait est là on voulait le faire oui
toute façon la dernière fois que vous
êtes venu vous parler de votre vie et
drogue la prostitution
oui puis en avez parlé de votre aventure
avec
on va pas recommencer on va passer à la
promo directement vous êtes prêts pour
faire des petites mains là j'étais bien
il faut pas dire ah non c'est pas bien
mais il faut rentrer dans le truc c'est
bof c'est ah oui pourquoi
pour faire la promotion d'un livre aux
éditions du cherche midi que j'ai écris
moi même et qui s'appelle
susan être exquis alors c'est un recueil
de pensées d'articles de texte
extraordinaire comme tout ce que vous
faites toute façon depuis que depuis que
je vous connais le ton est donné dès la
page de garde vous dites je n'ai plus
aucun propos dignes de confiance
j'ai tout dit j'ai menti à tout le monde
je ne sais plus ce que j'ai fini et qui
voit là comme ça au moins c'est un élève
non c'est pas la peine de dire rage j'ai
plongé dans mes souvenirs
ce que je dis est sincère j'aime j'aime
ça je veux faire profiter le monde de
mes découvertes et de ma connaissance
jeudi je m'en fous ça vous va bien un
trou de 90 balle c'est aux éditions du
cherche midi
voilà et c'est bientôt noël il n'y a pas
de raison
les décalages vous allez lire les
maximes que j'ai noté vous êtes prêts
oui page 14
l'amour est aveugle la preuve en le
faisant il ya des gens qui braille
[Applaudissements]
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur des
convoyeurs de son
21 7 21 spéciales après cambronne ne
mâchait pas ses mots heureusement pour
lui
24 les bonnes femmes sont toutes les
mêmes elles nous insultent parce qu'on
arrive en terre ils nous demandent
pourquoi on n'a pas appelé pour ne pas
se faire insulter deux fois gratuite
c'est quand on commence à payer des
pensions alimentaires qu'on se rend
compte à quel point moi ça passe vite
je vais continuer un peu non ça va ils
ont il faut leur laisser un peu j'espère
qu'ils achètent plus après non c'est pas
ça mais c'est puisqu'il toujours un peu
bébête quand quand on est quand on
raconte soi même les trucs 87 87
je serais à la place des agriculteurs
qui dépose du fumier devant les mcdo je
me méfierais parce que les gérants vont
finir par croire qu'il s'agit d'une
livraison
donc on va faire une petite interview a
redit view vous êtes près sûr
[Musique]
dans la bouche marbre
bien vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment
à rien je suis ici je pense que j'ai que
je me suis précipité sur un petit bout
de pain avec du jambon de bayonne
en arrivant il vous reste sur l'estomac
non je suis mais j'aurais dû avoir la
patience d'attendre pour la guinée quand
thomas voilà voilà
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous dites quoi
je regarde si je suis raccords pour la
barbe ah ah oui parce que si je peux
gagner encore un jour ça va mais si
c'est en tournage
je dis donc c'est rien là j'ai deux
millimètres de plus alors j'ai du boulot
non c'est très difficile où un boulot
non mais je veux dire c'est aussi dur
que ce sera quand vous étiez petit vous
auriez aimé ressembler à qui n'importe
qu'elle a dû arriver
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
j'ai même que des belles histoires
d'amour je n'ai pas eu une plus belle
que d'autres aient beaucoup hein
un paquet ait je regardais en préparant
les nations à ces normes
non mais c'est vrai paquet et des filles
sublimes oncle sublime pourquoi parce
que je suis en et rixe qui a montré le
bout cassant des vitres cassées dollar
est resté vrai alors quand on vous
demande des autographes
vous écrivez quoi ah bah ça dépend en
principe j'écris toujours dans la rue ou
ou sur un livre blanc dans la rue on ans
dans la rue j'écris bons souvenirs dans
les livres jeunes
j'ai pas besoin de faire grand-chose jeu
mais c'est bien vrai et c'est au titre
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois je pleure uniquement à l'occasion
du mort ouais c'était qu'il a tout le
monde est mort je sais que si vous
voulez j'ai fait une émission a
récemment avec un type qui m'a mis
devant une affiche de tout le monde il
est beau tout le monde il est gentil
keitel prolifique j'avais réalisé et qui
me lit il ya longtemps qu'il a vu cette
affiche
oui bien sûr et en temps et alors qu'est
ce que ça vous fait de la revoir
alors j'ai vu donc jean pierre rassam et
jean yanne présente jean pierre rassam
exit way un scénario du à resserrer jean
yanne pu dire si indique michel magne
plus de michel magne avec bernard blier
et moi vous changeriez qu en vous si
vous aviez une baguette magique
mon ventre j'aurai des abdominaux comme
des plaques de chocolat je rêve de ça ne
me balader sur les plages et que des
gonzesses se précipite sur moi pour
avoir mal
[Applaudissements]
vous trouvez comment bel homme ben ouais
c'est sympa robillard 1
quand on est prêt lui ça bah ouais non
c'est vrai il ya un avantage
considérable à être peuvent alors ça
c'est un truc que j'ai pu observer 100
milles soit quand on est poilu et barbu
on peut être gros et habillés avec des
choses rigolotes oui c'est vrai 1
vous prenez oui michel cardoze carlos
éminemment sympathique jean pierre coffe
il voit là il est gros bon ben c'est
bien il à la barbe
il peut se mettre des tee-shirts de
couleur des chemises hawaïennes bon vous
voyez pas je ce point comme ça non
quel péché qui vous tente le plus gênant
c'est l'avarice parce que grave crise
c'est le peuple c'est le seul péché
qu'on peut avoir même quand on est
pauvre jean yanne que diriez-vous de
plus négatif sur vos de plus négatif sur
moi vraiment pour vous auto cassé pour
mosley pour nous cela yama de rendre le
monde une fois pour toutes
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux ouais
c'est vrai je voulais dit et j'aurais
vraiment pu faire mieux si j'avais pas
été aussi flemmards mai
en fait même pas seul et mars et je n'ai
jamais jamais été un battant et donc
d'accès difficile je m'arrête
ouais donc je n'aurais jamais pu être
sportif franck leboeuf
moi j'aurais donné un coup de pied est
mort est un mec m'a effleuré le genou au
moment où chaque partie et le football
de ces jeux s'exerce que vous avez dit
avoir longtemps j'ai un gros défaut par
rapport au sport je l'est aussi par
rapport au spectacle
je reconnais pas les gens alors
évidemment j'ai une admiration sans
borne pour les mecs qui disent machin
qui passe à machin qui face à machin qui
les adorait les volants mais oui parce
que moi je vois un type qui pousse un
ballon qui donne un autre mais qui donne
un coup de volant et puis le stade se
lève et j'ai même pas vu passer le balai
comment ils font il met des numéros sur
le dos des gens à mon avis oui il faut
associer les maîtres même les noms
malandain et non un sujet qui avez vous
le plus envie d'épater monfils vous
feriez quoi s'il vous restait 24 heures
à vivre ce qui est bien c'est qu'en ce
moment cette question c'est vraiment gay
votre émission le cac40 s'est vraiment
c'est vrai que si j'avais 24 heures je
ferai pas grand chose parce qu'en 24
heures je n'aurai pas le temps de faire
tout ce que j'ai à faire et que j'aurais
déjà dû faire ouais mais je crois que
j'essaierai d'être avec eux
les gens qui m'aiment bien mais pas trop
pour pas leur faire de chagrin ouais je
me ferai un petit plateau télé
ouais je voudrais un petit whisky et je
mettrai la téloche voilà voilà
c'est terrible c'est terrible alors que
vous allez pas prier dans une église
dans un nom que vous je vais vous dire
très franchement à 24 ans ça sert plus à
rien salut tu te fous de ma gueule tu
vas pas te repartir maintenant 24 ans
c'est vrai que je n'ai comme aux usa le
problème est beaucoup plus
miséricordieux
non pas du tout ce que dieu m'a fait à
son image c'est bien c'est joli c'est
vous y serez surpris le surnom qu'on
vous donne que vous haïssez non non moi
ça me dérange pas les surnoms de toute
façon les on l'est on les oublie lens
qui me ce qui me tue mais ce qui
m'énerve c'est quand les gens alors
moins - maintenant c'est quand les gens
ne me tutoie dans la rue il mais il me
bouscule leurs jalons d'une part et pour
quand il ya tellement de gens qui
soutiennent non mais ça dépend qui aussi
je vois une fille longiligne les bagues
aînés de nylon celui sétois s'approche
de moi qui me dit dans un souffle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse l'affût revit enfin de sa
mort c'est ce qu'il ya après l'aller un
bien quand on y mourut ce qui nous
énerve le plus en vo j'ai pas le courage
de 2,2 de dire non et les choses qui
m'emmerde à mourir un tube on allait à
faire est ce qui vous énerve le plus
chez moi
non pourquoi non moi j'ai pas d'argent
on peut tout se dire ce soir
non mais je sais bien mais moi non
pourquoi vous m'énervez pas moi c'est
vrai oh non c'est sûr oui je serais pas
venu gens c'est un nombre même un peu
oui non mais j'ai même une certaine
passion parce qu'il est vrai que parce
que j'aime bien qu'il soit toujours en
noir ça te plait ça que chan
simultanément
[Applaudissements]
là ça va être moins gai parce qu'on
passe un e-mail consacré à notre ami
michaël blanc qui s'est fait choper à
bali avec de la drogue
ils ont fermé et mais qu'il a pris
perpet pour 1 kg 8 de shit dans une
bouteille de plongée
donc si on peut plus se mettre ko siu
lan longtemps il a plongé alors où va
t'on avoir tenu un mec était
pratiquement shit mois qui passaient les
bouteilles de plongée en fraude arrêt
dans des ballots de shit de 12 kg il
était une bouteille et pas eux non plus
alors je voudrais remercier les
donateurs au nom de la famille de
michael blanc pour le moment la famille
a reçu 20 mille francs
alors j'ai trouvé un truc c'est que si
chacun est à peu près 2 3 millions de
gens qui regardent cette émission si
chacun donne un franc le type est sauvé
oui moi je connais bien j'ai sauvé sauvé
à ce qu'il faut bakchich et pour le soir
jouer bien sûr si sûr moi j'y retourne
la valise donc avant ça le voit il ya la
prison de denpasar son nom mais c'est
vrai c'est rien mais là faut fournir
on pense qu'avec 1 millions 7,1 millions
8 voire 2 millions on peut le sortir de
là donc si chacun donne affronté
beaucoup fait un chèque d'un franc
l'adresse s'écrit en bas de l'écran
pendant que je le dis et l'ordre ses
soutiens michaël blanc voilà voilà
jorian je suis jeune et sexy
vision du circuit
des pensées des articles
formidable bouquin que tout le monde
doit avoir dans son avion j'accueille
maintenant victoria beckham
victoria beckham blessé le week-end
évidemment ayant vécu en angleterre
alors victoria d'abord je vais voir si
la traductrice et la belinda belinda il
a comme d'habitude prête à travailler
pour vous
linda je voulais vous dire merci un pour
l'autre soir c'était vraiment sympa
la tarte tatin la bonne paire toujours
au point faite maison
non la petite gâterie après l'émission
oui c'est bien ce dont je parle
des passants l'ont bien savoir corti
était ravie aussi je vais te le dire
mais c'est ça le monde virtuel en rien
du tout baffie l'éboulis a regretté de
ne pas être là je vais te le dire voilà
pour moi donc victoria bonsoir s'est
traduit chez les femmes 7,6 ok ça veut
dire bonsoir je sais mais si belinda des
fois là un peu du mal à traduire un peu
mais là ya pas de shanksville ok ça doit
être pas parfait parce qu'en france est
en fait trop horrible mais je peux faire
bed-in belinda est-ce que je peux
prendre ta place aux as que thierry dit
il c'est le chef a pas moins fait tu
capable de le faire ce serait
difficilement si c'est des trucs trop
compliqué non mais c'est une première
question ça allait bien c'est pareil
alors victoria bon choix je suis en
circuit maintenant si portage peut
traduire tout ce qui concerne la
mécanique des fluides
bien sûr
mon fils me suis spécialisé dans bien
oui alors victoria beckham quand vous
faisiez partie des spice girls sans vous
appelez poche parce que vous étiez un
petit peu la snob du groupe
la spécialiste des vêtements de marque
c'est ça fait il ya beaucoup de joie que
j'étais la personne qui avait le look un
peu le plus noble avec ses hauts talons
mais j'ai fait beaucoup plus de choses
j'ai créé un album est donc je suis très
occupé mais évidemment je vais au
shopping mais pas autant qu'on lit ouais
alors votre nom de gauche en course en
course annoncé les chevaux mais inactive
en course donc votre concours votre nom
de translate h is she is bad
alors qu'est-ce que je fais là rien
n'était aux yeux just ain draham votre
nom de famille c'est adams fait
particulier du minotaure
là on va de notre famille c'est adam
fait partie de la famille adams et vous
êtes marié avec une star du football
anglais qui s'appelle david beckham très
connue c'est une énorme star david
beckham le boeuf non salées vrai hein
savez vous l'aimez pas vous je ne
connais pas donc j'en parle pas j'ai
jamais joué contre lui plusieurs forts
coups de génie
on a eu quelques anicroches mais ça va
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
angleterre
victoria et beckham david beckham sont
un statut d'idole vous êtes un peu comme
diana
la presse anglaise aujourd'hui quand
elle met soi vous soit votre mari soit
les deux en couverture augmente ses
tirages de 20% fictivement des 10/10
était très snob et était vraiment
populaire mais en fait c'est parce que
mon mari a beaucoup de succès avec le
football et je faisais partie un espace
guerre mais c'était un groupe
extrêmement important évidemment
l'intérêt se magnifie avec ce couple qui
se forme très bien bien pour magnifique
pas mal comme un ce magnifique
avant d'être la femme de david beckham
vous avez été connu pour ça
m
et
[Musique]
celle là on va la voir en magnétos man
et auxerre
[Musique]
m
dénouer
[Musique]
moi
la maman
[Musique]
oh
didier en cantine
[Applaudissements]
ouais l'espace go 40 millions d'albums
vendus dans le monde
saleh serait
et aujourd'hui le premier cd solo en
solo ou à deux en france j'avais
commencé enfant à je vais t'apprendre
maman voilà les attentions
tu mets tes petites mains comme ça
attention victoria
elle le fait bien moi je trouve qu elle
le fait très bien bravo
je comprends que vous soyez devenu la
star que vous êtes alors donc maintenant
il ya un nouveau disque dont un single
est tiré et c'est ça
m
oh
[Musique]
non
ça s'appelle note search and in some
girls
ce qui veut dire jean racine de chercher
ça ouais je n'ai pas chaud ping
tous les jours je ne sais pas si
innocente que ça chante victoria beckham
vous dites sur cet album je ne suis pas
posh spice et des spice girls c'est pas
posh et becks votre mari c'est victoria
beckham pour la première fois c'est à
dire que vous assumez votre personnalité
ce que vous êtes vraiment en fait je
suis très fier de tout ce que nous avons
pu faire en tant que groupe et les
médias sont très intéressants parce
poche et les bacs mais j'en fais tout ce
que je voudrais c'est avec ma propre
identité c'est pour ça que je veux être
victoria beckham je veux qu'on prenne un
peu c'est très bon et quand on disait
voilà c'est moi et je suis très fier de
cet album que je j'ai fait je veux être
un individu à part entière et voilà
comprenez ça c'est un truc vous auriez
dû comprendre plutôt janssen jeunes
individus
je suis amené à vouloir mêler
et à la folle à former des groupes et
les choses banales aurait dû être
indépendant voilà comme tout le monde
mais voilà alors m'a regardé sans faire
des trucs comme espère girl et le
costume allait pas été ridicules man est
un serbe
je l'espère
[Musique]
m
victoria beckham sa journée un homme
semble laisser fêter sur la brune et la
blonde qui sommeille en nous voilà c'est
à dire que healy attendant d'en haut
fait l'ail et moi nous sommes à la fin
la blonde et la brune
ok alors et victoria c'est la même chose
voilà exactement la blonde et là je vous
préfère en brune
est ce que vous avez eu des déceptions
amoureuses avec des copines vous mais
non pas amoureuse amical ouais c'est ça
parce que le victoria une grave
déception on peut le dire avec geri
halliwell vous la considérez comme votre
meilleur ami votre blonde et c'est et
gerry qui a décidé de se séparer du
pacte vivent les médias aiment en fait
créé des problèmes qui n'existent pas et
repartent en angleterre il préfère
donner l'histoire négative que le
scénario positif c'est un problème à la
fin faut dire quand même déjà à l'école
vous étiez pas la copine de tout le
monde s'est déjà plaint de problèmes à
l'école vous dites on ne considérait à
l'école comme une extraterrestre
j'avais de gros problèmes d'acné c'est
vrai quand vous appelez sticky vicky et
vous dites j'arrivais tous les matins en
rolls avec mon père et c'est vrai que ça
crée des problèmes
en fait une bonne élève je voulais avoir
une bonne performance tu as travaillé
très dur que ce soit pour la danse le
chant
oui et c'était ce qu'il y avait à faire
à l'école et je pense que des enfants
d'accepter rabat ceci oui j'étais
ambitieuse comme votre père d'ailleurs
quelqu'un qui vient de la middle class
qui à force de travail à ganges
oui oui à force de travail il a monté
une entreprise d'électricité le père de
victoria
il a acheté une rolls et a pris date
leur ôter la vie de sa fille absolument
et à 8 ans
[Applaudissements]
non
à l'âge de 8 ans vous avez voir fame
d'alan parker et c'est un coup énorme
dans votre vie vous décidé à ce moment
là de vous lancer dans la carrière du
spectacle je suis belinda excusez moi
oui bien sûr si jamais le moment je suis
tellement compliqué je me demandais si
j'arrive à bryant et vous allez voir
fait il ya en a eu marre et apte à un
terme à mon avis il m'a prouvé que si on
travaille vraiment dur et on veut
quelque chose on peut y arriver et j'ai
beaucoup travaillé comme mon père et je
suis allé voir fait mais j'ai vu ces
gens sont lassés de russie mais c'est
moi je dois y être et c'est la même
chose avec david quand il regardait le
football on se disait si je travaille
très dur j'y arriverai aussi et rien
n'est perdu si jorian veut des
plaquettes de chocolat y pleure mais
bien entendu il suffit de regarder
franck voilà un nom mais ce qui est
terrible avec victoria sait qu'un jour
elle va voir mentionné de de cliff
richard bien sûr elle voit cliff richard
wembley a dit un jour je serai là et
bien avec les spice girls
elle s'y retrouver c'est vrai c'est ça
qui émerveillait pour faire un enfant on
se mord que de faire ce qu'il faut faire
ou pas faire j'ai simplement vu cet
homme sur la scène me suis dit ah je
veux faire la même chose ce serait la
même chose et vous l'avez fait
maintenant voilà et vous l'avez fait et
je dois continuer à travailler très dur
parce qu'il ya des gens beaucoup de gens
qui ont des préjugés comme vous l'avez
dit étant donné que j'étais la poche
la snobe on pensait que je ne faisais
que des courses et que je portais des
hauts talons c'est pas des courses et
pas de cheval faisait du shopping aller
au shopping vous décidez au jeu
contenant aller au shopi voilà et on
peut aussi aller au charbon
manière dont on peut faire du shopping
mais c'est en fait sinon rien d'isolé je
pars parce que bon patrick bélanger dit
on on dit pas on va au shopping dit on
va au cabinet pouvez-vous l'accepter je
ferai deux enquêtes inédites
j'ai fait au cabinet c'est vrai et alors
donc un jour je continue l'histoire de
poche un jour vous allez sur un stade de
foot et vous voyez david beckham et vous
dites je le veux awa thiam
mais c'est à peu près ça mais quand on
vous l'avait séduite innovantes ça est
fait je gardais du mauvais côté et au
travers de tout le match dont tu
regardais pas les bonnes et petit peu
mais quand je les ai vus après je me
suis dit c'est lui que je veux et
comment vous avez fait pour le gagner
avec son charme à votre choix à méditer
je crois vraiment la voir et on s'entend
on s'est entendus très bien depuis tout
début c'est que
ni testeurs tie break mais ne faisait
que commencer
et c'était quelque chose à plus bas
niveau que ça ne l'est mais vous verrez
donner confiance en lui et vous a donné
confiance en vous ils n'étaient pas en
train à bandol pas du tout pourtant ça a
marché global on va regarder à côté
malinois
[Musique]
voilà bienvenus
en angleterre vous êtes comme un couple
royal que c'est les médias qui - il faut
monter la sauce voulez mais beaucoup
david beckham est très amoureuse de lui
c'est vrai que vous l'avez ses shorts je
sais sa fin comment pourquoi les mariés
toujours bon pourquoi et marine et tu
comprendras
bah oui je trouve ça très beau de laver
les skins de son mari bah ouais voilà on
s'est mis en péril est-ce que vous la
verriez by sleep de l'autre mary n'ont
rien on est là parce que j'avais mal
mais mettra pas de slip
je connais un qui était alors en france
est un pays avec avec monsieur le boeuf
né mais thierry vous êtes vous êtes vous
ne mettez pas de slip donc elle peut
vivre
moi j'ai dit moi victoria il ya une
question qui est très célèbre dans cette
émission
c est ce que par amour vous embrasse
seriez sans fois les chaussettes sales
de votre amoureux c'est la question
clotilde courau que les habitués de
l'émission connaissent bien et si oui où
on aime et il voulait que je le fasse
oui oh la la
la pilule est comme ça j'étais tatouer
je vais me faire taper pour lui prouver
que je l'aimais donc savez les
chaussettes sales c'est pas trop dur ça
va me faire tatouer en effet les
chaussettes à ma femme j'irais pas
jusqu'a si ma femme très jolies pièces
en mouvement des pieds je pense pas que
bon bah oui c'est ça l'amour fringues
aph
je me lève je crois qu'il faut je crois
qu'il fallait au bout de l'histoire on
va faire une interview par amour on ne
bouge pas pendant le signal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter oui
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous convertir à l'islam
oh non non non non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
le visage par un chirurgien
il voulait lui
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 20 kg oui s'il fallait parce que
par amour c'est terrible vous seriez
prête à vous aiguisé en elton john c'est
dur je sais c'est dur mais bon quand on
aime quelqu'un en même temps tout ce
qu'il faudra que je fasse je le ferais
là est-ce que par amour
si ça le rendait heureux vous seriez
prête à accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse
non vous l'aimez pas vraiment alors
ça veut dire que je peux pas partager
quelqu'un que j'aime quand on fait
l'amour c'est quelque chose de
réciproque s'est décantée mais quel
point ils ont fait ça toi du respect et
de l'amour et s'il avait une maîtresse
ça voudrait dire qu'il me respecte
[Musique]
on aimerait savoir est-ce que par amour
ou seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
would you be comme sex live for love
tu vois et vous mais peut-être il est
lui-même mon esclave c'est ça l'histoire
les toits franck moi je suis l'esclave
sexuelle de ma femme quand elle veut
en solo
bon mais linda je vais te saluer mois de
mai bon comme d'habitude un à la
prochaine non voilées en ralé dont
victoria will tell you good bye
on va vous dire en forme maintenant
victoria très bien bye bye
see you soon
[Applaudissements]
vous
qu'est ce qu'on pense et fait quelques
pas en angleterre non ils font tout
court
ah ouais les contrats où ils ont des
contrats personnels avec les tabloïds
c'est des gens très c'est vrai qu'ils se
montrent énormément et que dès qu'ils
font un pas c'est vrai qu'ils sont épiés
mais bon il aime bien et ça devient tout
ça hein
ou pas la semaine dernière il est apparu
lui avec des boucles d'oreilles en
argent la montre en venant diamant le
montre entièrement la bague en diamant
voilà évident mais il aime bien ce à
quoi donc
bon ils peuvent pas l'intéressant ce
contre le busway maintenant nous
recevons
monsieur le monde
chapeau
oh
voici le directeur de la rédaction du
monde edwy plenel
elle dit également soir en soie vous
connaissez tous le monde est à peu près
quand vous êtes directeur de la
rédaction du journal le monde c'est pas
de la rigolade dans mon pote à je ferme
ma gueule depuis tout à l'heure je
disais les bêtises avant il à andy
rédacteur en chef du monde ma oui
surtout que bras
monsieur
bien vous publié chez stock un livre qui
s'appelle secret de jeunesse et qui
vient d'avoir le prix médicis de l'essai
vous savez comment faites vous je sais
je sais et oui ça va être votre tour
allons-y ouais j'ai une idée moi je sais
faire ça avait fait ça c'est bien aussi
c'est mieux oui c'est ça fait ça aussi
s'ils voulaient à nancy 1 2 3 c'est le
divertissement discuter avant avec jean
marie colombani bernard henri lévy pour
savoir s'il fallait faire ça ou ça ou ça
ou ça vous et baky c'est bien ça c'est
pas mal aussi ça oui non mais le livre
ça un conte une histoire on sait ça
assez clair alors on va parler de vous
de votre livre de votre vie attention
vous êtes prêts
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes né en 1952 la nantes
votre père alain était inspecteur
d'académie et professeur d'histoire et
vous avez passé votre enfance en algérie
et il faut attendre la fin de votre
bouquin pour que vous en donniez
l'explication
pourquoi vous êtes retrouvé en algérie
parce que mon père et a quitté la france
parce qu'il n'aimait pas le gaullisme
d'état réalisme policiers pas le
gaullisme de résistance et là on peut
faire un coup de chapeau celui qui il y
avait les humoristes
il y avait un amour de josiane pour
respirer un petit peu à l'époque
ouais le dire comme ça ouais donc il il
est parti oui enfin il faut dire aussi
qu'il a des intérêts dans un journal
algérien
oui dounia liste il était il était
contre le fait que la france où priment
d'autres peuples
ouais je peux le dire aussi simplement
que ça alors votre père s'est donc
retrouvé fonctionnaire algérien donc
pour y travailler pour le régime
algérien et c'est effectivement le seul
homme de gauche avoir choisi l'exil sous
le gaullisme d'état n'y a pas eu
d'autres exemples à ma connaissance je
pense pas enfin il a fait ça tout seul
un ouais il a entraîné personnes ouais
vous c'est une dette d'enfants sont à
lire comme ça au passé votre enfance et
votre adolescence en algérie avec un
père effectivement donc fonctionnaires
l'état algérien s'est assez mal payés et
d'une façon assez aléatoire alors vous
arrivé à paris en soixante dix en fait
fait sciences po puis du journalisme à
rouge qui est le journal de la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire de 76 à 78
ensuite le matin de paris et puis après
vous rentrez au monde et vous y êtes
depuis 1981 c'est quand même un bail et
vous vous y signalé par deux fameuses
enquêtes que tout le monde connaît la
sphère du rainbow warrior senet ça tout
à fait thierry medou turin turin
je vois ah oui certains datent du
rainbow warrior de lens c'est une
histoire qui a été complètement survolée
par monsieur fabius way qui a fait
plusieurs apparitions à la télévision et
qui à chaque fois mes amis une veste de
couleur
ouais c'est bien il en irait il est venu
par les époux tiranges avec une petite
veste bleu bleu ciel puis après rose
bonbon
après fuchsia et tout et il essayait de
noyer le poisson alors concert exhorté
les poissons avait été noyée depuis
longtemps voilà c'était de jute qui
était parti pour faire sauter un bateau
des trucs qu'ils auront petty dont dix
doigts et c'est grâce à vous qu'on a su
la vérité
ensuite il ya eu l'arrestation des
irlandais de vincennes ce qui vous a
valu d'être écouté par l'elysée votre
appartement fouillé vous en parler dr
dans un bouquin qui est l'un des sept
ouvrages qu'il a publiés à ce jour quels
mots volés et ensuite au monde vous
devenez rédacteur en chef
et puis en 94 et en 96 directeur de la
rédaction
donc finalement en 26 ans le jeune
étudiant débarquer d'alger devenu quand
même le directeur de rédaction du
journal le monde voulait dire quel est
votre secret ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que dans un journal qui fonctionne comme
ça les gars l'ont ils gagnent ou feu ils
viennent pas d'en haut
ouais il faut fonction marche la
collectivité pitoyable si ça marche pas
le miel a raison le monde se vend très
bien ça marche bien
voilà en plus le journal le monde doit
vous avez une émission à la télévision
une émission exemplaires sur lci qui
s'appelle le monde des idées vous
réussissez dans cette émission à faire
passer des sujets difficiles avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
je trouve qu'il ya un mépris souvent à
la télé enfin deux autour de la télé
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui ouvrent leur
poste
et s'ils ouvrent leurs postes qu'ils ont
ils ont fait la démarche d'aller voir et
donc je pense que si on interrompt
view des gens si on discute d'idées
importante il faut faut se démener pour
mouiller la chemise enthousiaste faut
pas être distant faut mouiller la
chemise c'est ce qu'on peut dire qu
avait fait des progrès comme animateur
de télé merci parce que non même
professeur pas du tout mais c'est vrai
qu'au début c'était pas évident et
c'était pas votre formation du tout et
vous avez fait d'énormes progrès vous
êtes le seul animateur moustachu à la
télé j'ai eu une barbiche des petites
lunettes donc dans mozart biche petites
lunettes trotsky bon d'accord mais j'ai
gardé la moustache
ouais voilà ça me va ça va pas trop mal
qu'est ce que vous en pensez la
moustache les sur 7 ce qui n'est pas de
stylo dans sa poche
ah ouais ouais si vous trouvez que ça
fait pitié les moustaches ophélie la
moustache la moustache ça chatouille
quand on fait des bisous résume le yacht
pendant une période c'est impensable que
le séducteur n'est pas des plus avares
aux l'air à la mode l'art qui rénovent
tous les mains calleuses mange août
c'est vrai la tendance
vous allez le meilleur vous même je la
mets moi quand j'étais baba méritent pas
d'y penser
alors toute façon vous avez été
trotskiste et vous dites j'ai été
trotskiste et je n'ai même été que ça
pendant dix ans de 69 à 79 en fait c'est
arrivé au trotskysme plutôt pas
anticolonialisme non bâti c'est l'idée
que le nord doit pas dominé le sud est
une idée qui a toujours une certaine
perte est très à la mode en ce moment
alors votre premier acte politique 767
vous avez 15 ans alger vous envoyer une
lettre à l'ambassadeur de cuba en
algérie après l'assassinât du che
guevara et c'est l'époque où vous dites
qu'il ya des phrases formidable et
pénales on se sentait convoqué par
l'histoire mondiale qui réclamait
l'ébranlement des très vieux monde
vous avez vous avez cru au messianisme
la révolution c'est pas être amoureux de
jean marie messier non c'est quoi l'idée
l'idée c'est que aujourd'hui on a on a
des révoltes assez obscur obscurantistes
fondamentalistes religieux
eux dont il fait mine is totalitaire qui
nous menace qui nous inquiète on les
voit là la cia les a laissé les a mises
en place elle les a mis en place en
grande part contre d'autres révoltes
ces révoltes celle des années soixante
dix quand on a dit trop de politique
tout ça on a bon ok c'est vrai on a fait
des bêtises on a dit des bêtises mais
ces révoltes elle était généreuse elle
était humaniste elle était féministe
elle était universaliste elle était
ouverte au monde
elle était curieuse de l'autre elle
était libertaire donc moi je veux dire
ça je veux dire que ces révoltes là et
bien on peut aujourd'hui plutôt les
regrettés voyez vous regrettez
finalement l'époque où on était tristes
now is communiste et c'est à ce qu'au
moins l'ambition quels qu'en soient les
résultats
l'ambition était noble et vous dites que
pour combattre ces révoltes là ce qui
était mis en place par la cia c'est
comme quand la cia est ben laden contre
les entre les soviétiques en afghanistan
c'est ça mais on a oublié mais toute
l'histoire de ben laden ça commence avec
le pakistan le pakistan c'est le seul
état des décolonisations du siècle ça
fait très loin un autre histoire qui est
un état qui se construit sur une base
religieuse
c'est l'un de ces gandhi et puis on dit
on va faire l'état des musulmans du sous
continent indien
c'est un et artificiels au départ alors
après bon ils s'arrangent ils
construisent tout de suite des régimes
militaires des régimes militaires
religieux à qui on laisse faire la bombe
atomique pourquoi pas parce qu'il ya les
soviétiques ça ça vient après mais c'est
aussi contre le tiers-monde contre
l'inde qui est un peu neutraliste
contrebande ou mme contre le fait qu'il
ya autre chose bon donc ça c'est les
créateurs c'est des pays non alignés en
49 ce qu'arnaud c'est les gens qui
veulent faire autre chose qui voulait
qu'ils voulaient sortir de l'idée qui
est fière d'eux
deux blocs voilà il voulait inventer
autre chose on leur a coupé les jarrets
ouais alors pourquoi le trotskisme mais
pas le communisme
parce que le trotskisme et c'est ça que
j'en retiens
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est au sein du
communisme ont critiqué le communisme
c'est à dire je pense que aujourd'hui
encore il faut toujours penser contre
soi même
il faut toujours penser y compris contre
ses propres préjugés contre une course
qui s'est pensée spontanée alors c'est
quoi le trotskisme on va sortir sans
problème trotsky il a aidé à la
révolution russe
notre série on peut le dire avant toute
chose chef de l'armée rouge
inventeur des cambistes
on parle toujours de trotski comme d'un
mec très sympa et à trotski sympa
staline c'est le méchant trotsky c'est
celui qui permet à l'union soviétique
d'exister en étant le chef de l'armée au
vrai mais il n'y a pas de trotskistes à
ce moment là alors c'est quoi le
trotskisme c'est que trotsky bombao lieu
désiré de ce combat ça et finalement ils
pensent contre lui-même peut-être pas
suffisamment
il meurt en 40 assassiné par un agent de
staline dans maman bio l'air d'un coup
de piolet le deuxième il est vieux mais
il arrive à empêcher le deuxième coup de
piolet il est très fier c'est le dernier
mot qui dit à sa femme il j'ai réussi à
empêcher le deuxième coup à résister
jusqu'au bout
bon avec cette crapule parce que c'était
une crapule celui qui l'a tué bon et
donc au bout du compte que c'est quoi la
leçon de tout ça mais trotskiste en
france dans les années 30 s'est sentie
s'est senti très vite dédié r&d variés
notamment des gens qui viennent du
surréalisme des gens qui sont y pense à
côté y pense compte donc moi quelle
leçon je retiens de tout ça c'est qu'il
faut toujours penser contre il était au
coeur du communisme l'idée qu'il fallait
changer les choses ils étaient sous
influence de la révolution russe la
guerre d'espagne mais il faut penser
compte il faut penser ce qui va pas par
exemple aujourd'hui bien sûr que ben
laden c'est effroyable
bien sûr que c'est totalitaire bien sûr
que mes revers tout ce qu'on veut ok
mais en même temps contre ben laden les
bombes à fragmentation qui restent
pendant dix ans qui font plein de
petites mines dans un pays où il ya déjà
eu un 12h30
mort il ya trois millions et demi de
personnes qui sont dehors bon ben non la
fin et les moyens
ben c'est plus compliqué la fin justifie
pas tous les moyens
il faut réfléchir aux moyens voilà ma
vue non c'est pas me lancer
non mais ce que vous dites est très
clair simplement vous vous êtes dans un
journal dans le patron s'appelle jean
marie colombani
quand il écrit en titre du journal nous
sommes tous des américains ça doit faire
un choc non il a dit nous sommes tous
américains
dans un éditorial le lendemain du 11
septembre qui est à la fois c'est
spontané c'est écrit dans la nuit on a
fait tous sidérés par rapport à ces tags
qui est un crime contre l'humanité que
la en actes totalité bien sûr donc c'est
le mouvement de solidarité instinctif
mais dans la foulée l'édito disais tout
ce que je viens de vous dire sur la note
à payer 2 comment les américains ont
géré cette région du monde
bon et puis le nous sommes tous
américains il voulait dire quoi nous
sommes tous new yorkais et ckoi à new
york new york c'est le mélange c'est le
brassage c'est le métissage c'est la
rencontre d identité c'est le fait
justement on n'est pas tous chez nous
dans de petites boîtes on est citoyen du
monde et on se mêle dans le monde
new york c'est ça et c'est ce symbole là
qui a été frappé alors dans votre
bouquin vous parlez de votre trotskisme
à vous ni à la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire il ya un autre
trotskisme celle aussi les lambertistes
c'est là où étaient jospin d'ailleurs
vous aimez pas beaucoup les lambertistes
vite c'est un peu la réincarnation des
staliniens
vous parlez même d'agressions physiques
des lambertiste du service d'ordre
lambertiste jospin pourquoi at il eu ce
trotskisme honteux j'ai écrit honteux et
souvent un peu de colère mais je dirais
vraiment c'est plutôt ça l'idée du livre
quand même c'est entre autres ce qu'ils
me malheureux j'ose pas un problème avec
sa jeunesse parce que il n'a pas pu tout
assumer publiquement il a vécu qui vais
schizophrène c'est une histoire presque
romanesque 1 il est un trotskiste la
nuit et sociale et ce jour mais bon donc
moi je veux dire que nos jeunesses moi
me je les vis toujours comme des comme
des enfants nos engagements et eu
souvent les anciens lambertiste y en a
beaucoup
voilà les milieux du spectacle il ya
muraille arditi et boby lapointe ils ont
ils ont un problème avec leur passé
trotskiste boby lapointe ses ventes
tu le crois ça à vanier framboises sont
celles annoncées dans son avocat je vais
bientôt ce qu'il chantait et moi je
l'aimé bien mais c'est vrai que l'homme
du devoir d'inventaire qui est lurette
j'ose pas on a du mal maintenant
apprendre qu'il a caché aussi longtemps
qu'il a fait ce double j'ai aussi
longtemps oui on a du mal banc face
était en même temps un secret de
polichinelle on lui a forcé ont la force
et le monde en révélant il aille il l'a
dit l'a reconnu je pense que depuis ça
le travail
c'est ça son problème c'est à dire quand
on fend l'armure vraiment ça souffre un
peu ça
il ya de la souffrance et je pense
qu'ils c'est son problème actuellement
je pense qu'il sera candidat
moi c'est mon analyse ouais mais je me
trompe peut-être que s'il dépasse ça que
s'il arrive à rendre compte de ça il n'y
a pas à avoir honte
et puis il ya les rencontres ça le rend
plus intéressant entre nous le fait
qu'il a été plus compliqué comme ça un
peu caché tout bon on peut discuter jugé
sa moralement et tout mais ça le rend
plus complexe
c'est plus intéressant plus compliqué
que simplement un type qui a été
renvoyée attention à ça parce qu'après
ça devient comme avec mitterrand on dit
il était formidable c'est un personnage
de roman ou un florentin et ça fait
excuser un peu tout les temps passés on
juge sur les actes ouej le politique ses
actes le dernier bouquin de son
directeur de cabinet dit qu'il faut
juger les politiques comme sont cochées
elle conduit bien où il conduit mal
ouais voilà c'est alfred de vigny en
fait est ici de ça le direction qui le
premier collaborateur de jospin il dit
voilà les politiques c'est y conduisent
bien où conduisent mal alors c'est pas
vraiment romantique ça moi je suis un
peu plus romantique c'est vrai la
question d'actualité vous pensez quoi du
recul du soutien français à l'action
américaine
en afghanistan je pense qu'on a on a cru
un moment qu'ils allaient réfléchir
qu'ils allaient pas faire exactement la
même chose et puis hélas ils ont ils ont
répété un scénario prévu bon sincèrement
ça sert à quoi de faire des frappes
qu'on a vu déjà bagdad on a vu déjà à
belgrade qui jamais ne sont assez
précises qui font toujours un régal à
côté sur un pays qui est un des plus
pauvres de la planète est un désert
alors qu'ils ont pas aidés l'alliance du
nord qu'ils ont pas aidés massoud qu'ils
ont pas aidé les opposants ou talibans
bon donc évidemment que bon il ya un
problème qui s'appelle ben laden ça
c'est un problème policiers c'est un
problème de recherche de renseignements
bon c'est de longue haleine mais là bon
il ya la façon dont ces menées bon les
militaires disent vous verrez le
résultat
mais il faudrait pas que le résultat
nous amène bon les mêmes conséquences
jean vous continuer à aller aux usa
régulièrement à prendre l'avion à ouvrir
là depuis quelques quelques
jours oui je continuerai planche puisque
la barre à new york à peu près à 500
mètres du sap était bon il faut
continuer je trouve que ce qui est tout
à fait surprenant c'est que les
américains sont devenus depuis quelques
temps un peu humble il ramenait un plus
à ramener beaucoup en disant à tout le
monde il peut rien nous arriver on a mis
au point un système imparable et puis
d'un seul coup les barres et nous aussi
on peut en décrasser oui ça les hommes
mondialisée les états unis vivaient
dominer le monde mais dans leur monde
arabe où dans le monde sera de la pire
des façons ce rappel a eu donc en effet
ils sont dans un souci du monde
bon le problème c'est qu'il faut ajuster
quand même sur sur l'asie centrale et
l'afghanistan mais merci
os qui va vous arriver c'est terrible
d'être vie plenel je m'attends au pire
alors si vous avez beaucoup de travail
pas beaucoup de temps pour et dans les
boîtes de nuit
donc on va vous faire une interview un
petit peu spécial la bouche pendant le
génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'interview proust express spécial boîte
de nuit
mais d'abord il me faut mon dj c'est une
boîte de nuit mois ci à philippe corti
sow
il
voilà donc ambiance boîte de nuit une
musique de boîte de nuit et
l'interviewer
[Musique]
et puis plenel c'est quoi pour vous le
comble de la vie
alors
[Musique]
mon coeur
aucun de nous
jean le mensonge
et
[Musique]
ça c est qu il a fait
kelly
bush est là
l'amitié
et c'est là bas
qui auriez vous
tu me tiens prêt
m
rêver être guevara mais justement ce que
vous
[Musique]
l'envi
la tuerie
[Applaudissements]
musique
hier
vous
sa présence
autant on rallume
emad au soleil mais des dentelles et
étayé
voici benjamin biolay
là
on doit
benjamin biolay vous le connaissez
benjamin biolay c'est un songwriter
comme on dit maintenant producteurs
aussi et il est coauteur avec keren ann
oui non mais les vues à la télévision et
vous aviez une autre coiffure vous aviez
des cheveux plus courts et je vous ai vu
en tournée parce que je regarde beaucoup
la télé en tournée ouais vous parliez du
10 d'henri salvador de votre prochain
disque que vous étiez en train de faire
de françoise hardy mais vous aviez les
cheveux plus courts et moi ça m'arrive à
vue de combien de temps j'ai vu la
semaine dernière la copine ion ouais
j'avais l'esprit - propre moi c'est bien
ça vient j'aimais bien et je veux ça oui
non mais je voudrais savoir pourquoi
edwin s'appelle edwin est vie et il n'y
a pas de haine
c'est vrai non non non c'est en fait
c'est saxon il ya eu un roi bien son nom
vous voulez vous voulez pas
pendant dix mois edwin et dwan a battu
edwin edwy parce que edwin c'est un
saint celui-là on n'oublie pas la tête à
ça
edwin et pince il a été roi saxons au
10ème siècle il est devenu roi 16 ans et
il est mort à 19 ans dans la débauche
après avoir épousé sa belle-mère voila
voila je pense que c'est important qu'on
parle un petit peu de benjamin qui s'est
fait un brushing pour ce soir et corps
et portait un disque que les très beaux
divisa ben oui ça a été facile d'écrire
pour cette valeur
dans un premier temps pour la première
chanson ça a été facile ce que je
pensais jamais que ça aboutirait donc
c'était comme comme de rédiger un
scénario pour hollywood sur la mrie est
pour l'a déjà pour la 2e sur 100 c'était
plus délicat parce qu'il était mais vous
connaissiez son oeuvre sérieuse qu'il
avait jetée très fanatique de trenet
salvador
cette école alors quand le disque est
sorti vous étiez en belgique en train de
préparer le veau dont on va parler et en
fait on a beaucoup parlé de keren ann et
pas beaucoup de vous et à un moment ça a
dû vous gonfle et non à mort non mais
c'est vrai oui pour moi j'étais en
belgique c'était un peu je m'enfermais
pour écrire et enregistrer mon album et
j'ai complètement raté
on m'a dit tu sais que henri salvador et
multi platiné que mme hanane est une
star mondiale et oui je me suis dit ah
mais c'est bien sympa non n'hésitez pas
à jouer sur les kennedy
bah justement d'en parler voilà onze qui
surcroît kennedy et sur la famille en
général ça n'est pas tant qu'ils
s'intéressent à cette famille en
particulier mais ils trouvent ça
charmant
j'ai entendu dans le reportage c'est
comment on fait benjamin oui là vous
êtes passionné d'histoire un moment où
j'étais un peu ça vous donniez un peu
vous sais pas trop quoi faire et vous
aviez à beaubourg et vous cherchez des
documents sur les kennedy et pas
seulement les comédies mais j'étais
désargenté aussi mais je donnais à la
bibliothèque de beaubourg dont je
pouvais passer de vraies mitterrand les
bains avec de l'eau du robinet delà de
la pure et mousse chaude
[Applaudissements]
alors dans la main oui si vous êtes
fascinés par le mythe kennedy par le
destin shakespearien de la dynastie et
c'est un concept album autour autour de
ça certaines américain peut un peu
cliché on peut dire non un peu cliché
hollywood
ouais la croisée des chemins entre le
showbiz et la politique enfin quelque
chose oui marilyn et les kennedy c'est
ça qui vous pas nécessairement marilyn
mais peter lefort le beau-frère du
président de la cavac sinatra dean
martin
[Musique]
celle-ci se soulever
si peu c'est tout
[Musique]
sous
là vous avez tous fait la parole et
musique j'ai fait la plupart des j'ai
fait tout sauf trois titres le carnac ou
composer ouais mais quand vous
travaillez avec keren ann vous faites
comme lennon et mccartney s'est dit pas
qui vous êtes toujours copain avec elle
la marge est la 13ème la sur
médiatisation d'un tel était le but
c'était juste un moment un petit peu
délicat à passer on ne serait pas prêt
en fait un succès aussi important ce
n'était pas une autre en même temps mais
on en a quand même les répercussions et
êtes tranquilles financièrement
maintenant moi ça va hein cherche un mec
avec terrasse
alors on fait tout ça vient le concept
album l'idée vient de melody nelson que
vous avez entendu vous êtes d'ivoire 13
ans le 10 de gainsbourg
si vous a fasciné c'est un grand choc
pour vous ça m'a fasciné
j'avais d'abord découvert aux armes et
caetera way qui était le premier 10
français que j'ai vraiment écoutés mais
pas de mélodie steduto cover ex voyage
était fasciné par le son du reggae et
tous mes mélodies nacion m'a amené
ailleurs ouest et alors vous avez écrit
depuis l'âge de 14 ans à peu près 500
chansons ouais mais des daubes
abominable ah oui avoir écrit 350 truc
épouvantable
ouais vous avez l'oreille absolue c'est
à dire que quand vous entendez une
chanson vous entendez toutes les notes
avant je l'avais plus c'était très
pénible que j'allais écouter un concert
de musique classique j'entendais toutes
les notes c'est fini ça je serai à jesse
louis pourquoi dieu soit loué c'est un
cauchemar alors est en concert le 12
novembre à l'olympia dans le cadre du
festival des arts hoc
et puis on va vous faire une petite
interview
technicolor puisque vous êtes fascinée
par hollywood
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
l'ennui fichiers way bleu de peur
de devoir parler devant des gens que je
connais pas c'est vrai ce qui vous rend
rose de bonheur le sexe et si vous fait
rire jaune les gens fils tendance à se
rabaisser pour montrer à quel point ils
sont superbes à la fausse modestie ni
fausse modestie pardon ah oui d'accord
ce qui vous rend rouge de honte d'être
mal coiffée quand l'âge des réflexions
comme annoncé au blind test spécial
girls band
j'appelle un homme dessus de tout
soupçon pour arbitrer ce blind test
match et un philippe bardy
[Musique]
là
cortina pas de culotte bien attention
dont le girlsband je veux le nom des
interprètes didier attention sans son
numéro un
mais bon
c'est ballot
suprême non c'est gilles paquet brenner
qui a trouvé ça fait un point pour cette
équipe la numéro 2 didier
ce genre de mec du coin sont les tudors
les sky blues n'ont alors attendez tu as
des as titia du calme sinon y'a des
habillages voilà didier
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
3 0 pour les masters ouais je crois
qu'il va revenir pour les masters les
voilà attention didier non non non
les filles du calme enfin comment vous
pouvez connaître safran c'est le premier
gang band de notre génération
vous l'avez reconnu à la première note
je l'attendais
disons que je mal pour attention ophélie
a pour se réveiller mais là attention
didier
mais ce qu'ils font
alors il ya soufflage quoi ça sert
[Applaudissements]
c'est le mercier donc c'est catherine
barma mais j'ai causé
c'est toi
enfin que tu as en d1 combien mes vignes
1,4 très bien continue dj fiche
et
combo ses pairs
à pâques heures d'appels et h 1
en continu didier aulas je fais
j'ai encore
oh
ouais
m
comment vous avez ça jacquet ou quoi
vous avez dit jean des soirées il était
déçu mais c'est bien il a faim beau film
est gagnable un appartement il est en
train de planter tout le monde il est
ainsi ceux déjà lu on continue didier
provost
le réalisateur johnny chan est en train
de faire ce que l'appartement j'ai lu
ici la valise il a fait un cavalier sur
10 ans a marqué 7 points
didier
non
il a
oh
si m
football est bidon mais s'est pas mis
dans tous les sens et james énorme
non mais ils sont là à connaître moi je
connais les parisiennes parisienne
georges milton les parisiens c'est très
bizarre ce qui est en train d'arriver
elle avait une boule de feu on continue
m
je demanderai au public de ne pas
souffler sinon je comme j'ai de faire
évacuer la salle ou de faire déshabiller
par ja oui didier
m
ces métiers accès au jeu touche pas une
bille il ya peut-être un truc pour toi
lapin
[Musique]
m
non merci
non elle sait n 5 ne doit pas faire ça
tu te mets pas à côté de moi tu te mets
deux bouts là haut tout seul et le bout
et avait de regarder la bombe en plein
débat sur la tête plural plus haut bien
attention ça tu peux savoir plus
ça tu peux savoir didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ici peu
gilles paquet brenner
gagner cinq plus que ça et plus que ça a
joué dix points bon mais qu'est ce qui
se passe là bas on a tant parlé musique
alors qu'on peut faire actionner son ex
amie voilà c'était tout moment par
émission lambie sexe magouille et
culture générale
ophélie winter gilles paquet brenner
pour les jolies choses de gilles
paquet-brenner avec marion cotillard
comines belgique sa tribu
petit le 14 novembre en salles valérie
lemercier du 11 au 15 décembre à
l'olympia en tournée au 6 novembre à
clermont-ferrand le 8 à 10 il
guy labour et après à la rochelle gros
globe capitaine rêve merci paul ii venu
campagne télé
m
jean yanne
joyal je suis allée tricks qu'ils
recherchent
merci jean victoria beckham
e
le 6 novembre 110 ans en vente ça
s'appelle bibi voilà et le single
s'appelle note cette année neuf singles
fbi p
secret de jeunesse dit mais d'ici je
sais et c'est chez stock
merci de pas mal d'être venu voilà on
continue
benjamin biolay kennedy le single
s'appelle aussi risqué mais du grand
concert le 12 mai
à l'olympia et le 18 décembre à l'elysée
montmartre et pour finir philippe maury
il à monsieur philippe bouty vivre là
quand iberia
son nom
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
à voir
[Musique]
une
je vais voir
jusqu'où
[Musique]
têtu
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
oh
et
à des pièces de notre région